- hello world here I am from another
dimension
reporting in I am in a meditative state
reporting from the enlightened dimension
to tell you that this is gonna be a
really good podcast today and I'm back
you through buying your host thank you
to equip and stamps.com for sponsoring
us today we've got Gus Johnson there he
is go ahead and put the camera on him
I'm back here I am back again and and we
have with them today
Eddie burr back in the flesh I'm here
for the first time also hosts of Gus and
Eddie podcast the boys what does it mean
to be a boy yeah well we go out of our
way to assert that anyone can be a boy
absolutely anyone I don't care if you're
a lady or a man or a dog anybody's a boy
your boys your buddies yeah that's
pretty much it yeah if it's you support
your boys then you're a boy can you be
dick out like dicks out regardless of
gender yeah yeah and you guys you know
James Charles has like the sisters or
whatever this isn't like the flip side
of it but we're just saying the boys
it's not a it's not a revolt against not
like a rallying cry okay now you guys
live together yeah how long have you
guys been living together we moved here
in July of 2018 right it's like a year
and a half about a year and a half
where'd you guys move here from I'm from
suburbs of Chicago Chicago I'm from
nowhere Wisconsin and how did you guys
end up how did your paths cross here in
Los Angeles how did we we started DMing
each other I think like I we saw each
other's videos and we were super small
and we were just like you know messaging
back before I opened up I sent him just
a picture of my [ __ ] and then it was
just boys will be boys yeah but no yeah
it was I think Gus had a video that was
on trending it was like should I always
forget it was it how to be a professor
yeah that one and I just liked it and I
went to his Twitter just super low
following nobody gave a [ __ ] about this
guy no I was crazy yeah and so we just
started talking and then after that we
had we hung out like two months later
and then we're just like real-life
friends young men and so now living
together for 1.5 years mmm you you are
you're not you have a girlfriend you're
not it's not more developed yeah yeah
yeah I mean Sabrina yeah you two years
yeah okay [ __ ] our anniversary just
happen I took her on today you remember
I did remember they you celebrated its
its lucky cuz it's like I have like her
birthday our anniversary Christmas and
then my grandma mom and sisters birthday
are all in the first two months of the
year so I just boom boom boom boom and
that's find that very helpful it's nice
because I would I'll be honest with you
guys up until like two years ago I
didn't even I couldn't remember
everyone's birthday I still I know three
people's birthday and my family I don't
know my sisters my dad's my mom's
birthday yeah I was like so like like
such a psycho
I up until two years ago didn't know my
own mom and dad's birthday I mean I knew
that general time yeah good thank you
and I know you're sweet man so I know
that now I'm better person I thought it
was yeah maybe you're worse than I
perceive you to be I think I'm worse I'm
worse than you in this sense no I can't
hold numbers and dates though like I'm
good at yeah mean [ __ ] but me numbers
are now Eddie do you have a significant
other no not currently okay
well phil was sure to press me on that
on his podcast what I'm just curious
about is that you we have a situation of
two young men living together how does
how big is the house you guys ever have
these are conflicts but see with you
guys living together was it the most
I was delicious you have dish problem
yeah no we have an AC problem I was
[ __ ] with the AC a lot like cold or
hot I like it warmer little bro but I
mean that's literally probably the
extent of yeah what temperature you guys
i'ma say if it was our this a/c unit we
have you know sometimes when the actual
temperature seems to be different for
different places yeah
73 in our place
I think is like pretty good but when Gus
was on tour those times I was cranking
it down to 68 every day yes I love it
for me it's frigid I'm a little cold
baby I like it 75
me too good blend but yeah we're 75
we're 73 and right away that's what you
wear in the house you know and I wear
shorts even wears nothing short all year
I was shortened Yeah right
except that there's winter where you're
you the guy that does that like shorts
in the winter like when you were in New
York or whatever no I pushed as far as I
could but some days work besides just
looking like an absolute freak like
you're trying to make a point
yeah if you're walking around went there
in New York with shorts like this what
tough yeah if you wear shorts in the
winter though and you admit it's cold
you're fine it's the guys that won't
even accept it at all it's like we all
know we can feel the same thing you're
feeling I was freezing I was 13 I was
freezing through my long pants there but
but so we've got we're back in the house
now now tell me about the situation when
you prepare a meal in the kitchen do you
clean up your dishes immediately
afterwards or do you sometimes to leave
them in the sink I sometimes we leave
mine I do too
yeah it's I mean that's the thing is
like if you I know some people are like
real strict about that you know of like
cleaning it up immediately but it's like
I don't know sometimes you tell about
you guys but it doesn't bother you
mostly the perpetrator so sounds like
I'm like pushing it home to you oh no
he's chill with it but I just I you know
sometimes all I have a really bad time
especially I'm shooting videos like I
get in that mindset where I'm like I'll
take this out and like a [ __ ] I could
take that load laundry put that over
there and I get done I'm like I can't
touch that you know like I built up in
my room that's right I just you don't
see it so you ever end up washing his
dishes well we have a dishwasher so yeah
putting it and I have am I kind of have
a beef with dishwashers they're not that
convenient because you still have to
rinse the plate right yeah if you just
put it in dirty it's gonna come out with
[ __ ] on it yeah that's so do you ever so
do you ever rinse his dishes I mean I'm
sure we've there's been crossover either
way but yeah there's no like there's no
animosity not really not really
interested in that because we used to
live with a housemate our friend Sean
but hello
the the dishes it's kind of like a thing
like oh I don't know if you guys are
sugarcoating it I've had a lot of
roommates in my life and the dishes was
always a point of conflict what in
college for me it was huge yeah I
terrible I think what we get here is
that we way too many times order food in
so there's a man brother it's a crab
make and tell me how many bathrooms too
bad too okay that's actually on our I
think last episode of our podcast I was
saying that I'm so glad that this was
the first time I cuz I went to Community
College so I lived in my parents until I
moved out here and it was the first time
that I had lived on my own I was so glad
I didn't have to share a bathroom with
somebody they shared a bathroom with my
siblings my whole life and I'm like I
don't know so not my family if I could
do it well I'll tell you a story
our good friend Sean shoutout we would
we have shared one bathroom with him
more in Israel I listen there's no easy
way but if there was jizz and the jizz
doesn't mix with water and there was
jizz wait like in the tub and stuff like
at the drain because there's ink no in
the shower sink because there's like
[ __ ] there's like review absorption the
shower the jizz gets stuck at the drain
and I would have to be like Sean you
have to go clean your jizz out cuz I'm
not I first of all obviously not touch
it
I'm not going to shower in it those
those difficult conversations I said
dude you can't jerk off in the shower
bro or at least you you got to make sure
it goes down how much hair was in the
drain even that you don't know what I'm
talking well I don't either there was an
absurd amount of hair in the drain or he
has the no it's missus no it happened
because jizz back me up you guys know
what I'm talking about right like jizz
can get caught in the drain I I actually
do have your back on this thank you
mixes with the hot water it like
coalesce is in today I think cold water
to make it harden up like a shrinky dink
or something well whatever temperature
the water was yeah and I know this is it
then cuz you know well frankly it's just
boy things
[Laughter]
what else alright weekend-long is the
biggest yeah yeah there's some there's
some conflict here I mean there's any
like friend like an occasional
disagreement but you we leave pretty
much where you guys disagree about I
don't really like it's only been like
small if we're ever like I can only
recall a couple of times where there's
just something where it's like a
misunderstanding and then we just kind
of figure it out yeah yeah we seem like
very sweet guys the two oh yeah we [ __ ]
yeah for sure no that's drink yeah we
drink you drink what do you guys drink I
sometimes I'm just like a normal whiskey
guy and then now also I've been having a
lot of the seltzer stuff on the crave
bills for the seltzer yeah I had I
really liked um I had it recently it was
your friend Curtis brought it which it's
a like High Noon it's a vodka and they
have different flavors but it's like
vodka and pineapple juice and it's
carbonate carbonated and I like it that
a lot oh the murmuration what do you
drink
see I'm hard in the seltzer game I'm
happy with I went kind of as well LA
when I came out here I'm hard sell sir
yeah I'm doing hard seltzer I'm we're
drinking the Dasani sparkling and
Lacroix and [ __ ] I'm doing Booch every
day now I will say at heart I think
we're Bud Light boys yeah we always will
be drinking like nitro cold brew dude I
can't have caffeine anymore I don't know
what what happens I don't know sometimes
in the last year I start getting panic
attacks mikemaya theme
yeah I mean the tour started it was when
the tour started my chest got heightened
I couldn't breathe and it was fully like
hey sit down I'm gonna spin I'm gonna
pass out Winston me too but I'm so
interested in drinking coffee do you
work through it I go I guess I don't
like when warm beverages and now I can't
drink caffeine so now I'm that guy when
I do under like a Starbucks I'm like can
I get a decaf
I think I stand on caffeinated drinks do
I do that yeah like you're at the wrong
story idiot okay so we got a couple guys
drinking seltzer alcoholic seltzer
you're in your living room you guys hang
out I'm assuming on a nightly basis
there what are we doing we playing video
games watching TV
yeah yeah a lot of the time we'll have
like main room hangouts usually when we
have people over and then a lot of the
time we'll play video games together and
then with like I said of our friends
online playing in a room separately but
we're playing together yes and then
during the day we're hanging out in the
main room more mm-hmm what are we
playing dude we are we're hopping on a
lot of PC [ __ ] lately we've been into
more how lately that medieval kind of
like COD in ancient times kind of [ __ ]
we played raft what out what is out of
raft right now it's kind of in demo
we're just kicking around a couple of PC
this reminds me so much of my times with
Sean yeah yeah good time land party
stuff well I had a the man who was kept
choosing in the shower situation there
but you got your young men I mean what
you guys is age I'm 23 yeah yes I was
that age at that time yeah now I'm old
[ __ ] I'm 34 I got a kid so video
yeah but my only chance to play video
games is that like 11 yeah
to 3 a.m. damn what are you playing
we're like legitimately old now yeah
it's official yeah bro maybe 35 I've
been playing Diablo 3 on ps4 I actually
got into Diablo 3 cuz yeah my brother
got back into it yeah ps4 and I'm not
and I'm not trying to flex but I am
paragon level 525 dan didn't play it
enough to know what that and that's
impressive right I think so and I'm on
the greater rift level 63 working my way
up wow that sounds impressed one more
time to fritter so oK we've got the
vision we're at the house you guys
living together what's the plan do you
guys wake up in the morning and you have
like a workday ahead of you Gus that's
way more than me I mean my little post
videos why yeah I was about to get to it
first then you got me I'm just I am real
slow with it I like to wait til there's
something that I really really want to
make a wave of inspiration and then I'm
also just a terrible procrastinator so
what do you better not rub off on you
when you
you guys like grinding no yeah I know we
do like I I don't have any interest and
I don't think I could do the kind of
videos that Eddie does cuz there's so
much like comedy lievable into the
little details I really like it like
just the intro cards and stuff to all
the transitions I just get so picky and
editing where I'm like it sounds like a
[ __ ] nightmare I don't want to do all
that [ __ ] you guys - you have very it's
clearly very different approaches to
making youtube videos
mmm get him you're like a Viner really
in your approach to youtube it not too
and not as a hint no I don't take it
like they're sure they're catchy it's a
fun little concept you put it in boom
boom Bob's your uncle what do you post
something three videos a week yeah well
I've been dial it back to like one two
at the most right now okay I kind of
like every six seven days at the moment
for the most part right now that's just
because like we got the podcast every
Monday - and just like I'm trying to
shoot with like Comedy Central and stuff
like I just don't come back to that in a
moment
you post once every six months I mean
this this is unacceptable I just don't
know what you think what look what do we
do what's the plan it's still going well
what it could be but like I mean we
expect better we expect more from you it
could be going better but I'm so happy
with my catalog and that's why this is
the longest I've gone I'm editing a
video now but does the longest have gone
without uploading I think ever look we
know road to take though they're being
so picky mmm you cannot wait for
inspiration I have somebody I mean I got
it but yes it's the thing is it's got
are you working on a video yeah and how
long have you been working on this video
well I shot it about a week ago and then
I really got into a week ago you shot in
a week ago yes I'm saying but I posted
right before Thanksgiving which isn't
good but it's likes giving like on
YouTube time that's like a whole if I
come back and the video is good then who
cares we extrude Eddie do you ever feel
that like for example you guys came
together in this house Gus is a prolific
creator I want to
I got insert myself the only reason my
output is able to be so high is because
I have Sabrina litter
full-time working as like a salaried
employee of my LLC so daily she's there
to do like all my contacts all the
producing she films much I appreciate
that we all have the ability to you know
but I'm just saying I listen listen I've
I understand there's no excuses here I
just want to understand what's going on
with Eddie do you want a new Christopher
Nolan movie every year man needs I
wouldn't that's that's a fair I mean
that's okay but do you ever feel maybe
pressure because you're in a you're in
this house with Gus's prolific creator
I'm not as prolific as you well he's
growing its sub count what are you
what's your sub count now I think I hit
like 500k like two weeks ago or
something yeah nice you should have much
more than that
well I congratulate you on that
milestone do you ever feel like man you
know does it do you ever feel so maybe
like I don't know like like let's let's
you know let's get it going here a
little bit because Gus what are you at
now in sub count I don't know right I'll
stop I don't know one point seven I
think milli okay okay
I felt that before never it's never like
a competitive thing I never bet avoid an
altruistic way but like mmm no I maybe
like me being left behind and in some
way not exactly because especially when
I wanted to do YouTube the idea of 500k
was like insane to me worse and I think
it's mainly I don't really care like I
really welcome and really like people
more people enjoying my videos but it's
all to me about what like the content of
the video so it's like yeah I could post
more like I've had times where when my
videos were worse I was posting like
once a week for that month and it was
like my biggest growth month ever and
then I looked back at the end of the
month and I was like yeah the numbers
look good but i hate three of these
videos I was like so I can't keep doing
this I would rather just like you're a
man of quality you're a man of and and
okay I did I think for both of us do the
big milestones like once you hit 100k
it's like oh damn like yeah this is it
see from I I found my Smike my thirst
was over
um quench really yes what was always
like super happy with any milestones
yeah cuz I what was the big one for you
guys you're like holy [ __ ] out I mean it
took us like a year together was insane
every ten thousand fifty thousand a
hundred thousand a million two million
and then I guess I stopped yeah I
remember to on my old college MacBook I
kept the tab open when I was at like
9999 yeah I kept it that therefore I
served a note that I left Ethan when we
passed a thousand because I think I went
to school or something I quit my job
yeah College yeah you were but um I left
a note for you like thousand thirteen
yeah I still have it oh you do that was
a great time that was a beautiful time I
mean it was so exciting but I'm just
trying to get to the heart of your
philosophy of creating your ears is one
of certainly kwant
quality over quantity and I will
celebrate the quo of your videos I mean
the level of detail and research and
scripting that goes into it is is
phenomenal and I do encourage people to
watch but you but it's an uphill battle
on YouTube mmm you know what I'm saying
it the platform unfortunately it makes
you decide right between like you said
doing a month where you post more and
and you put let you have you just simply
can't put as much effort into it by that
or or taking your time and unfortunately
the platform is just a little bitch-ass
well that's what's nice about the
podcast editor to write is I can do
something every week that we do and
that's not like the podcast is never I
was already like this with my videos
before hands but like so it hasn't I
haven't used it as like a crutch for it
but it's what's nice is like I can do
comedy I can post a video I like on the
podcast channel and then I can still
work on my stuff I am too slow with my
stuff though like it's a lot of it is
not working on it all the time a lot of
it is like sitting down trying to edit
an intro hating everything about it and
being like I can't look at this today I
gotta go back to it it's cool though
that the algorithm is less strict now
like people can have big careers and do
that like Nikki JK is a similar up
load schedule people can can just put
out one big video or even every few
months and it doesn't seem to
necessarily just hurt that mean that's
true I mean Shane Dawson as a point
yeah well jontron was like it's one that
proved it to everyone because I think
before him we all had this like idea
that if you kind of disappear for a few
months your channel will not do the same
look but then he would go and come back
and it's not a point so yeah flexi was
fifty million views I saw that yeah
that's got to be one of the best
branding opportunities
honestly it's like that and like a like
Papa bluster like Papa John's are like
speaking yeah he looked less sweaty in
the video yeah he probably had AC in
there you only had about you know what I
should know what tree Papa with all the
tenderness and care yeah that I would my
own pizza are you are you gonna eat
pizza on the podcast I'm thinking of
different things that we can do with Tim
Pizza taste test yeah blind taste test
that's great all of the brand's yeah I
think he's gonna have he's gonna know
though but that's interesting I don't
get my pizza quiz like terminology and
yeah like that I feel like the whole
thing is so surreal that I'm still not
even believing that it's happening that
is whatever yeah well the truth is
though I'm mostly interested in his
pizza conspiracy story he has quite a
story to tell
yeah about how he was ousted as the as
the Papa do you think it has he been
really vocal about that in interviews I
know he had that kind of like blank
threat you know the day of grab this is
the day Monday is the day of reckoning
least this is gonna be Lee has receipt
he's bringing he's probably missed
rolling with faxes from like 1990 Big C
I'm telling you I don't know if I can
reveal it okay I probably can yeah well
here's what he taught he I was on the
phone with him the other day
uh-huh the phone calls the news for
Turia's phone call yeah he has it way
he's bringing it no we're gonna play it
on Monday cuz
hurt it right now I don't think so yeah
I can't believe we that because he says
he didn't say that n-word
whoa yeah the day of reckoning Holi is
coming to the h3 podcast on Monday I
mean he called me yesterday Papa I
called my private number so let me see
the private number I'm like Papa all
right six seven
but anyways enough about me we were
talking about Eddie what's the plan I
think what you you you think we find it
really interesting your approach because
for us personally it has caused a lot of
stress and negativity in our personal
life when we went that route because
it's so hard to the rare too close to go
like the purity mode where I'm only
gonna post if it's good and I'm only
gonna make a video from a hundred
percent right interested I think what
the big change a lot of it has been I
mean not only talking to friends like
like Gus or drew drew gooden or jakey
where the big thing that I found wasn't
waiting for like a good thing to come
along but making a video on what I was
interested in at the time because I
started finding that those videos did
well and I didn't think that they would
we're like even my last one has I guess
been like my biggest video now and I was
like oh I keep bitching about all these
late night hosts and I don't know if
people will care at all and then I made
it and people watched it that's such a
good point because I think that that on
face value you would never think that
people on YouTube would give a [ __ ]
about late night about talking adept
about late night people but you were
actually I was I was not expecting the
video that I saw it was a very earnest a
very sincere video one that I agreed
with and I thought was very thoughtful
and interesting it I mean that means a
lot I hate to I don't be too kiss-ass
here but like he's and I got in the
commentary with you guys it's especially
even the specifically the b44 video one
of my favorite videos thank you so much
yeah it's so kind of you to say yeah and
so like I mean I'm sure you guys have it
too though we're with a lot of the like
more you to be commentary stuff you just
get so [ __ ] tired
about it yeah yeah I'm I got so tired of
talking about like a youtuber I found
that did something kind of apps and yeah
so like I made one sort of like that
recently but it had to do with like Hulu
and everything and that was enough of an
angle oh yeah it's just like making
stuff that you want to talk about seems
to be the most interesting thing to do
it's fun people [ __ ] love it too
they'll watch like if you care about
something they will listen to you you
know like Drew Gooden is doing like like
loved hers
SNL comparisons and stuff for like
friends versus in the office mixed in
with like look at this weird guy and
Instagram you know you got Eddie's
late-night video and stuff like I'm I'm
trying to follow the same route like
into this new year like I want to do
like a mini documentary about like mad
magazines cuz I used to read those old
ones when I was a kid like just pick
something that you're excited about and
like that's really cool that people want
to see they're so ferret that's good
advice that's a very good insight cool
and I can't agree more I mean that's
that's basically the reason why I
stopped making videos was because I
think what I cared about at the time was
all these prank videos were just so
[ __ ] and nobody on YouTube was talking
about it and so I just got so charged up
yeah and it was really resonating and
that's kind of what like launched our
channel but after years and years and
years and then the genre of commentary
become more popular it felt to me that
that it was just I felt like I was my
soul was was evaporating with every
commentary video I made about some
stupid person on YouTube doing something
stupid you know that that ten people are
also work you know that ten people are
working on the same video I'm like you
know so that's kind of why we why we
pivoted and and that's all I have to say
about that now where do you see yourself
in five years five years I don't know
because I think when I try and think
more kind of grand things for us
separately or together if we're doing
something that's like traditional at all
I usually picture us being a bit older
you know because I don't think I don't
know I think a lot of the time like
because I more of the time I don't want
to be somebody who's like an actor in
something but usually I want to like
make stuff and so five years hopefully
using you
to make things maybe not on YouTube but
still still making videos and I only
upload once every six months so that's
only in ten videos
well I my intention is not to disparage
your uploads only but I want to say cuz
I can already hear the comments now
saying that Ethan is such an [ __ ]
I get that every episode though so I'm
used to it but but that I encourage you
to follow your heart and I think your
philosophy is a genuine and a beautiful
one No thank you I appreciate it but
also I should be uploading more it's I
know you don't mean it well that angle
but like I didn't I don't work as much
as I should yeah so it's very young man
you're sipping Bud Light and you're
playing video games I am 10 years older
than you so you know you have you have
life to waste yet you're very young what
is this call me central business what
what what is what is this partnership it
is so I was approached by like their
digital team I think about a year year
and a half ago right at the tail end
when I was in college to go and be kind
of a part-time creator in New York I
wasn't able to accept that I would had
to kind of [ __ ] over my whole theater
production it's a full-time job what is
this job they offer it was it was my
understanding that it was like a regular
staple like you're one of the people in
the office that are creating online
content it I just wasn't able to do it
and I was just like well [ __ ] I missed
that boat there goes Comedy Central but
then I came out here and shortly after
moving out to LA we got in contact again
and now the what the deal that we have
is I will go to like live events for
them sometimes I go go to like South by
or comic-con or something and I'll do
like man on the street just kind of like
[ __ ] around with people stuff but I
like doing it like that because I'm
pretty much always the butt of the joke
in like I feel like I don't to be the
man on the street that's going up to
people and just poking and prodding [ __ ]
so I'll go and I'll do that stuff and
I'm also contracted to send in like a
bunch of sketches for their digital
department stuff so you write sketches
for them yeah so I'll do that like that
you're not in that no that I am in so
I'll so it's fully is like I will
produce it entirely out of house and
I'll just edit it and I'll just send it
and they pay you yeah they pay you perv
it was a bundle deal where it was like
including all the live stuff and like
this amount of sketches they paid me a
chunk for it but nice and like are you
happy with the I'm happy with everything
over there yeah yeah the only thing I
dislike is again it's it's difficult
sometimes especially with how I like
doing [ __ ] sometimes it's so on the fly
you know sometimes I'll have a sketch
idea and I'll start filming 20 minutes
later and just and whip it out there it
is cuz if you just sometimes all you
need is a single joke for a 30 second
video so I am so disorganized in that
sense and just making stuff up that it
sucks sometimes when I have to like wait
to have them send like a representative
to come over to make sure everyone signs
waivers and there's insurance and I
think it's very like hey oh there's a
brand over there we can't have that so
it's it's it's not as much of an
environment where I can just quick make
[ __ ] i running it through so many people
is difficult or a little goof yeah at
times yeah and it's like I understand
the corporate structure over there but
it's like doc I'm making it yeah come on
you know like I'm taping a wig to my
head what am I sure it's for this I'm in
my living room you know do you make a
lot more money per video when you make
for a Comedy Central than yourself no I
make more for myself oh well then what's
the point the point is its Comedy
Central and I think that that's like a
valuable inroad for me I'm not getting
just absolutely screwed by them at all
like it I think it's a fair deal for
what we've got right now okay like
numbers-wise
and it is kind of close to what I do
make like video isin so they post it on
their channel mm-hmm they pay you but it
is a good you're making connections with
people there yeah what do you want to do
a comic central let's say that the CEO
says hey Gus he says nothing not the
devil he says what do you want to do
here's a blank check I've talked to I'd
like to think that we have a really
great relationship we've been working
together over about a year and a half
now you know we've talked and this year
I'm gonna start kind of sending some
pitches over my five years from now
thing is I want to be writing and
running my own show I don't know
starring it I definitely wanna be in it
too yeah and we become not a sitcom
company my ultimate dude I want to do a
sketch comedy show more than anything do
you guys ever see I think you should
leave on Netflix
that's the [ __ ] shot immediately what
I thought of damn it dude last time I
had an audition for that show you did I
did I had an audition for it was one of
my first auditions out here and and like
it was a great situation and then I got
[ __ ] pneumonia for I didn't get the
job but oh because I couldn't send in
the audition and then and then once I
finally got enough to talk I call it my
manager at the time was I can talk
enough like God please send an audition
he goes I already cast the part I mean
there is a one-line position that you
can take and I was like okay so I got in
like a 45-minute uber to Santa Monica I
walked into a little rent in office for
like the casting thing I walked down and
for this one line character they're
already like 12 names on the sign-in
sheet so I just signed my name
cuz Johnson and they call me in it was
just one woman with a little like 2003
home video camera in there she goes go
ahead and I was supposed to do the line
of like my dad had died no speaking at
his funeral so she just goes go I was
like mmm
well my dad was really she stop stop are
you way too sad go again and I just did
it a little SS it really is like that
yeah it was just like all of that hop up
for one line yeah [ __ ] sucked
so how many times to do it I don't I
don't do a lot of like auditions you
didn't get it I definitely didn't get it
too sad I was so [ __ ] bummed and I
you read it too sad I was the main
audition I had was for like a main
sketch character in in multiple sketches
and I couldn't send that 1x I couldn't
speak because well yeah the two
different ones were the original one was
the the like the clown video one were
they returned to it right yeah the the
sad one was the like playing the crazy
ordering and thread willies breaking
[ __ ] so hmm
stop stop fasting directors I again I'm
the guy that went to like to in-person
auditions so I'm not mr. Hollywood with
a lot of knowledge that one was just a
definitely really kind of I can see that
though they're like I don't [ __ ] have
time for these because to them they're
like this is all just a bunch of garbage
up
and I don't write to like here's here's
no I number 12 coming in to cry for this
one guys number 12 stop dude again I'm
sorry to interrupt we got to go to break
okay that was a sound bite but it's
still true but it is I don't think that
Oh Bobbie Lee the comedian was gushing
his heart over his dad who had recently
passed away
uh-huh and and Dan that's of sound by
talking about his recently deceased
father
so we cherish that sound buddy and we
will honor it by going to break so do
not go anywhere we will be right back
with the boys Gus and Eddie if you leave
you are gonna get Corona
there's a reason that three million
people are using the quip electric
toothbrush because it's affordable and
it's amazing basically it's the perfect
value and experience you're gonna find
anywhere for a toothbrush first of all
it vibrates vibrating every dentist will
tell you vibrating tooth brushes clean
your teeth better - it's got soft rubber
rub rubbery bristles that I've not felt
on any other toothbrush that are so
sensitive and they don't agitate my gums
and by the way when you over agitate
your gums they recede and they never
grow back you need to take care of your
gums and three it times out your
brushing experience it it when it's
vibrating it lets you know it pulses to
switch quadrants to give you that
perfect two minute brush so every 30
seconds it gives you a little pulse and
you know to flip you're gonna want to
use this clip it's gonna change your
life
gonna have a cleaner mouth I don't to
say it's a revolution
what's the quip revolution join three
million healthy mouths at just $25 in
the door and if you go to get quip calm
slash aged through right now you'll get
your first refill for free so that's
your first refill free at get quip calm
slash h3 the spelled GE t qu IP comm
slash h3 quit the good habits company
stamps.com what a stamps.com mean to me
as a business owner it means no hassle
it means not going to the post office
fighting traffic waiting in line all
this bureaucracy it's done
stamps comm posters have gone up again
it keeps going up thanks stamps calm
eases the pain with big discounts off
the post office as well stamp stuck let
me say five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to forty percent off
shipping rates that kind of saving can
really add up especially for small
business plus stamps comm is completely
online it saves you precious time time
more valuable than any research resource
on this planet no more inconvenient
trips to the post office post office com
brings all the services of the u.s. post
service right to your computer whether
you're a small business sending invoices
and Orla or online sellers shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
Sam comp can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US posters 24/7 on any letter
had any package any class of mail any
where you want to send once your mail is
ready you just hand it to your mail
carrier to drop it in a mailbox it's
that simple
stamps.com not only saves you time it
saves you money too with Sam calm you
get discounted postage rates that you
can't even get at the post office so why
bother even go in there when you can go
to stamps calm not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost and these expensive
postage meters forget about it there's
no equipment to lease there's no long
term commitment it's easy it's a
no-brainer at stamps Calm saving you
time and money
it's no wonder 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm
right now for my listeners you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in h3 stands calm go to the
microphone at the top and enter h3
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back we are
joined by Gus and Eddie the funny one is
prolific and one takes this time we're
gonna go home with a host you know
what's funny though is the room like the
marriage story room the one with the big
meme screenshot of Adam driver coming
out like how dare you compared to me to
my father that looks almost exactly like
the room door to our hallway I didn't
put a thing on Twitter of you
I told Tony that about that it looks
like the like our hallway going to our
bedrooms it looks exactly like it we
were watching it yeah and he walked past
it up for a second I was like wait no
that's not our apartment yeah and while
every didn't punch our wall well I'm
gonna tell you I refused to watch that
film
everybody's watching everybody's trying
to get me to watch that film I'm not
gonna watch a film that I know it's
gonna depress me
it's about two people have a divorce I'm
in a happy relationship they got they
have kids right they get divided like
you know what I don't need that element
in my life I don't want to get it I feel
the same way I won't watch that movie
and I know this thing out on allegedly
really good are not missing I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't want to be sad from
lovers I'm missing out I'm not being sad
for a day yeah yeah because I watched it
and I like told even uh because my
parents are split up and I told my whole
family I was like it's a good movie but
don't watch it yourself it ended and I
was just like I just feel bad now I was
on a flight it didn't feel good and the
same thing there was like a Nike ad
during the super oven was talking about
about like some dude with Alzheimer's
remember or not Nike Google I remember
when his Oh his wife who passed I'm like
first of all I refused to watch the
commercial I am NOT gonna allow Google
to make me feel [ __ ] bad for this guy
like you have nothing to do with this
guy's life [ __ ] Google for even track
like how does Google get love for their
exploiting this poor man with
Alzheimer's I don't I don't even know
the premise I'm assuming that's what it
is it it you know what I hate is it
looks like a really effective commercial
have you seen it yet I have no wait have
we not watching it let's pull it
yes really sad Zack you cried but I have
things to say that's the problem Zack
said it made him cry made me fall okay
fine and because the situation is
genuine and beautiful but why the [ __ ]
does Google get to put their logo on and
own that moment it's kinda hilarious
like the big evil CEO comes in goes look
human yeah [ __ ] at see that but I
refuse to I don't want to engage with it
because it is gonna make me sad yeah
well we're here together if you want to
throw it up because now I don't have a
friend they went yeah if they claim this
because I'm like how are they my team
there's layers econo - bro
oh there's music yeah there's like a
piano yeah when I watch trailers and
they claim my entire podcast I'm like is
that not the mother-loving point yeah
yeah what you want people to go see the
[ __ ] movie okay well so there you
have it um I do have stuff I wanna watch
though this was inspired by from you
Eddie
no nice weather is a this whole oh yeah
Robert Patterson is the hottest man in
the world according to science he has
the perfect eye position the perfect
nose with the perp a actually not
perfect sorry his lips are only 82% so
he's got to work on that he needs
collagen or something he looks like he's
sucking his cheeks in like that yeah
yeah well his Chin's at 95 and his nose
lip with this look this right here is at
eighty nine point four he's got some low
marks here I'm not quite sure why he
feels beautiful I just do it hmm I
should try that you don't look like
Robert Van Leer watch this meted you're
golden ratio rating is [ __ ] low low
watch it this is Robert Plant our
Pattinson with plastic surgery already
his face shape are you gonna give his
face a rating when you just slammed on
his lips
yeah his foreheads of 93 his overall
golden ratio rating
is a ninety two point one five according
to this plastic surgeon by the way
trying to pitch +32 even him yeah so um
well who's who's your hottest actor
right now who do you think is the most
attractive male actor period I've always
found the most attractive male actor to
be Paul Newman dad is a [ __ ] good
choice dude Paul McDonald salad
dressings yeah I see him daily put Paul
Newman here but do not [ __ ] that's got
bad aging if I look like that when I was
seventeen Luke he I think like in movies
he's just so [ __ ] cool like yes love
his whole swag dude for me it's like my
old school cool throwback answer is like
80s Harrison Ford oh he really man right
how did his ass otherwise you and
McGregor these days though he's aging
now NY what are you [ __ ] talking I'll
tell you hey my food that you and
McGregor uh you see the only one obi-wan
he's not aging poorly but I wouldn't say
he's aging like fine
yes his wrinkles every new wrinkle I go
mmm now let me tell you why I hey man I
don't like him I'll tell you why
let's see here is how it looks reasoning
masters within the lab you want to die
by the way don't look at how I typed his
name I'm gonna score factor 2020 he's
getting hotter ela
go ahead rate him I mean is good-looking
but not like he's not your ultimate not
ultimate he's my number one to use my
Costanza won't coming from an
unblemished record of staunch
heterosexuality wrinkles in his face
yeah the smile lines I like I like
mature yeah I like immature yeah I like
maybe it's the facial hair though
because yeah they say facial hair makes
men look better but look he's got that
Kirk Douglas rest in peace the Kirk
Douglas chin you know a little dent
there here's we're gonna tell you about
you and that I don't like what's up my
first girlfriend ever in high school she
just would not shut
about how hot he was and in Moulin Rouge
and I was a very insecure young man and
I just was like I don't and I didn't
look anything like him yeah and I was so
in love with her and I was like what
that hated his guts that dirt nasty for
this is hey I'll tell you I don't get it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] dude I had a girlfriend
in high school that did that with her
like I was just on Facebook in class and
I was scrolling through and it was just
a kid that I played basketball against
from like a town over and she was dating
me at the time she goes whoa stop I was
like what she go scroll back up oh my
God look at him hallelujah I was like 17
see that that's the kind of damage that
never be so as a fifth grade my first
girlfriend the first day we were dating
we were on the bus cuz we lived in the
same on the same street and a friend
asked her like just like why are you
dating him and she said I'm dating for
him for his personality not his looks I
was I was just so heartbroken by I was
doing my homework and I pointed like I
agreed like 2+2 I want to die yeah have
you ever had a moment like that ELA were
with like but you're beautiful and
perfect so who would ever say something
like that about you yeah I got nothing
what do you mean if I had what moment
cuz a moment that shattered your entire
self-confidence forever yeah we've all
got one I don't know I feel like for
girls it's so hard it's like every day
that's a good point
like people comparing you to other
people or what like just sighs just
seeing everything I don't know by the
way you have beautiful breasts I'm not
I'm not going to diminish the I'm just
saying God has a slender girl you
probably were very insecure beautiful
now solid d-cups were you like
especially where I don't know if it was
something while I was growing up or
Israel or I don't know if it's really
like that too but a lot of the girls in
my class were like I guess titties
really big really yeah I wouldn't
insecure about like dude so many things
growing up my head is pretty big head
and when I was a kid the thing is I've
all ever since I was like four
it looks like my have just a receding
hairline I have a [ __ ] huge head like
a receding hairline already yeah it's
just I got the head shape I was always
self-conscious at the same hairline yeah
I've got pictures when I was ever tried
to do weird haircuts yeah when I used to
try to do the lampshade you know in
middle school where it's like a bowl
it's like it's kind of the bowl cut but
with the flappy wings out here like the
guy with the lamp pictures of that I
look hot as [ __ ] you're mine kid I don't
know that's I'm not seeing any young
ones of me just there's me in college
and there's the sportscaster That's not
me I don't know if you hey guys oh wow
yeah he does look like a sharp dude I
think he's like 52 - eh very well now
here I noticed you are you hiding your
hairline in this one that one is just I
mean I've had the kind of boy flop over
to the side for a while I've been
washing it that's me also YouTube
creator home skill in town and in
college oh yeah that's my one of my
hometown newspapers they've honored you
hate it thank you so we were talking
about we were talking about insecure
face perfection yes thank you bring it
all back I got more to share now
according to the same people Bella Hadid
yeah has a the perfect female face
although they didn't do they didn't
crotch as many uh really as many data
points see I she has like work on her
face right I don't know actually so
young about be it that would be such a
shame I kind of have the thing where I
like I look at her and I'm like this is
inning
beautiful woman it's too good but it's
yeah like my heart doesn't jump out at
that cuz I was like I like kind of
swinging in just around my weight class
you know what I mean and this is to
punch off efore mean I agree well there
there are like perfect beauties that I
that I find that I'm more attracted to
yeah you know yeah I feel the same way
woman though her eyes is that is a
ninety seven point six five percent
where it's like it's no question she's
gorgeous but like my heart doesn't go
like oh my god cuz I'm like I want like
that that's like a supermodel oh you
know what I mean mm guys stick with my
man you went on this one who do you who
so who's your tummy Ella who's your
perfect male beauty go ahead but when
you showed him is when he was young Oh
your nose yeah oh very like perfect face
if I oh my god
point one yellow it was pretty I just
don't even know I like it was calm you
haven't seen a ball you haven't seen a
Paul Newman movie I don't know he's just
so [ __ ] cool dude right also his
charity by the way what you see
everywhere yeah come on dude it's raised
like half of someone nice to Jerry's oh
he looks like skeleton he's Jewish
is he oh that just made him ten times
harder for me I feel like I go with the
classics like attitude they like James
Dean I don't know I like the class oh
yeah here's a picture look at that yeah
I like you like the Caprio they don't
make them like they used to did this
look at that face dude but yeah that's
pretty sharp Brad Pitt though and once
upon time Hollywood though specifically
movie it was like I love that movie I
like today ever it is such a long time
yeah I really liked it I like I kind of
liked it being longer you just kind of
living in Texas for a while you know
okay well I made one I actually put my
face in the a really wait was there an
actual program you could just put it in
yeah yeah it has
dicken balls is one of the rate of mine
says penis 300 percent so here's the
what the a I did so the I position 1
percent birth defect question mark the
lips - 50 percent
this is pedophile negative 50 percent of
having pedophile lips which I hope
though I'd rather be mine at 100 chin
certified bitchin - a hundred percent
for had great hairline I got good scores
on that that's a good one that one I
actually scored higher than Robert
Patterson yeah nose to Jewish obviously
2% and the golden ratio rating it didn't
even give me ranges said ugly as [ __ ]
I'm surprised they would even coat it
like that and I did one for each of you
guys to up no I'm kidding especially I
already have one you just make one
that's way me well you're supposed to
you yeah I didn't even see the golden
ratio rating for it so I just missed
that and that's why I'm bad at my job
it's this stupid thing it's everywhere
it's like some have it some don't
yeah what are you guys feeling about the
coronavirus you scared are you excited
yeah you know what after the swine flu
the market was wide open I know I'm not
scared about it I mean I'm not traveling
anytime well [ __ ] we're going to Orlando
in a couple weeks
yeah that's not China I will die in
other ways you might get more there yeah
we'll get eaten by Gator shanked by a
meth head or something but I'm not super
scared about the coronavirus I I think
it's probably a little more like media
fodder than then is an actual public
health concern but it's still scary as
[ __ ] know do you know that scene in Lord
of the Rings where Strider goes yeah he
goes are you scared yes he says not
nearly enough that's how I feel both you
go Jew you call him Strider yeah that's
right or Eragon Strider
I [ __ ] I'm a huge Lord of the Rings
fan oh really love them you read the all
them.i multiple times no here's the
thing I'm a fair-weather fan I'm an I
adore the Peter Jackson movies I read
The Hobbit I really like The Hobbit I
read the first book and I said and then
I read the second book halfway through I
was like I can't [ __ ] do this I can't
read description of meadows any longer
I'm - it's not for my brain I'm not
smart enough for it because it really is
like there's so much cool beauty and
like grandeur in the world he built but
you have to slog through like ya pages
of a bill 'full for son of [ __ ] duck
you know I'm just yeah it's like the
Bible bucking decks my favorite well
whether you're scared or not oh I watch
the directors bad bro dude you only are
you kidding me we watched him three
back-to-back when we were in Israel had
nothing to do with our lives what was
that like a 13-hour mayor oh I did it is
actually it's 13 I loved it though it's
great and the thing is it's like -
they're really good theatrical cuts -
there's just stuff that you can't
explain in there in the original cut you
know like like the whole relationship
between like Denethor and like Theoden
is not really explained a lot anyway I
like the extended editions so I did as
well
if you have 13 hours to it yeah
but regardless of if you're scared of
the coronavirus or not there are some
wonderful memes yes that have come out
about it so here in China they have like
they have curfew and you're not allowed
to go outside and they have this PSA
system on a loudspeaker huh
and what someone someone fell asleep
behind the microphone oh no and it was
broadcasting vice or no audio and I'm
about to have a diva moment it's muted
it's muted on yeah on the browser so
you're saying it's not your fault can I
blame how can I blame you again yeah I
sabotaged I came in there don't do that
this is real yeah it almost sounds like
a siren yeah it's almost scarier than
nothing can be actually scary anymore
memes have ruined everything is a
perfect case in point it's like if I if
the world was ending if a nuclear bomb
went off in New York yeah their memes
would come as fast as the news yeah no
probably like people be tweeting writing
into the [ __ ] Apple and other things
yeah
is that cool or not cool I think it's
cool I think it's I think it's a very
self self-realizing meta way of like
just humanity gone yeah are you guys I
remember on it like an older podcast
think you're talking with post about
like doomsday [ __ ] I know he's kind of a
big prepper guy do you guys have any of
that kind of like I made I made a go-bag
a couple of months you know yeah of
course or what I mean of course I'm
[ __ ] our one if in your living room
drinking sparkling seltzer for what
well we split off for it because when we
were talking about doomsday stuff I
stocked up my closet in the apartment
with a bunch of water and food just in
case anything happened
Gus seems to think he can get out of Los
Angeles with a backpack on his back I
don't know how you would live now just
for the first 48 Eddie wait what's in
here what's in you go back I got a big
like it just looks like our / mol ninja
[ __ ] like this terrible like military
looking backpack and it just got some
basic [ __ ] in it like I got a first aid
kit a solar charging like USB thing for
phones and stuff is like so struck and
he's gonna kill you and take the bag I
can't pack for tomorrow like I'm not we
had to make a go back when I was
pregnant for the hospital and we
literally did like the last week and
yeah you know when it's gonna happen
see I can't I can't pack for tomorrow
but I can pack for the day after
tomorrow that's a good reference I like
that was one of the worst movies it was
so I just don't understand it you really
think something's gonna happen I I don't
it was I just be prepared
yeah I just finished Breaking Bad for
like the 8th time it was like prepared
so what what what in your mind is the
situation where you're like I'm grabbing
the bag and I'm hitting the road well
clear yeah Eddie asked so many times
that one [ __ ] you're not touching this
[ __ ] you'll get the water supply my foil
blanket is it a is it a act of wars a
terrorism is it natural disaster it's
it's I got a little bit of cash in there
I like maybe $300 in there looking come
rob me there's nothing in the apartment
and like you know a first aid kit and
then just a couple like it's like pro
what are we fighting for
we're preparing for if I need 48 hours
of just basic needs okay anything
systems go down I got a little cash for
on the street well that was the thing is
it was posing you really think people
are gonna be accepting cash in a
situation like that do something
probably it was right after the last
like big earthquakes and so that was I
was like oh what if the water shuts down
and Gus is like what if I need to escape
fight my fellow man head toward the
desert and I should be fine so you guys
got a little spooked by earthquake you
you you aren't earthquake boys no yeah I
wasn't here for it and it was I was
flying back the day after the the second
one that was bigger they're like yeah
there's gonna be another big one so
flying back felt really weird where it's
like I might actively just be choosing
to go to an earthquake right now no I
I've been here my whole life as dude
it's the worst I was in the most
compromising position ever for that last
really big earthquake I was like very
drunk and I was taking a bath in it like
candlelight a bath I was in the bath
perfect it was like Mac Miller was
playing and I was just chilling vibe and
just blasted out of my mind and I was
like kind of just grooving back and
forth wow this is really beautiful like
the waters moving with me wait the
waters [ __ ] moving right now [ __ ] was
going down and I was soaking wet
and I was just like I ran out I didn't
have a towel in the bathroom so he what
so I ran naked through the apartment
into my room and I I put on like shorts
and a shirt soaking wet and I had to run
down like 12 flights of stairs you know
and I just remember I was like
have a heart attack like cuz I was
running back to you dude well just cuz I
was blasted and then I was soaking wet
running down like 12 flights of stairs
like my heart's k people were like
screaming in the stairwell as everyone
is running down the stairwell and then a
door slammed and a bunch of people went
yeah let me tell you what what I know of
earthquakes they the people who the most
injuries happen from earthquakes are
people who get up they say stay where
you are really stay where you are and
just wait for it to go away because most
people will get up and run and they'll
trip although something will fall on
them yeah just get to a place where
nothing could fall on you and continue
to don't more harsher chill bro but let
me go back to some of you so do you
often take baths kind of frequently and
not as we like anything though right
it's a sensual yeah
it's chill you smoke weed I do a little
bit and you you get do you usually get
like mega blasted in the tub no it was a
bath bomb I love bath bombs it's so you
know he does this I take showers and
then I generally wash but once the bath
bomb makes it so I can see you watch him
anymore
well I guess the show's over you take a
bath yeah now that's why he's obviously
using a lot more water run every day so
I take two showers a day okay so you
think that even though our apartment
complex pays for our water the rent
which recently because my [ __ ] tub
has been like gushing water for months
and I've called in the complaint like
nine times and I was so mad that I
calculated cuz I thought we're gonna
have to pay it and then I realized oh
[ __ ] they pay for it how interesting
dude it is waste in the last few months
my tub exclusively has leaked 18,000
gallons of water oh that's not good I
literally go to the administration for
it fixing it yeah well so you're in the
bath you've got the candles your what do
you do you just relax do you do anything
in there do you read I wish I could
redyed [ __ ] dip the book in the water
but it kendall have waterproof Kindles I
could do that sure then I have to read
like a [ __ ] nerd do you ever be in
the tub
I don't pee in the tub why would you do
in the tub like during the best
questions like or maybe right at the end
a little tub of piss bisque I don't need
that I don't hold the drain before it's
coming I just I chill in there I get a
couple scented candles get my mrs. Myers
Iowa pine scent candle light that up a
little Mac Miller on the Bluetooth
speaker and I just vibe for how long you
in the bathtub you be an hour and and
basically until the water comes to a
point where it's no longer comforting
yeah I'm straight prune and every time
I'm in there interesting a very sensual
experience I like it are you bath guy
you know what's more yeah I started
taking back that it's not sensual by me
yeah I actually all like what listen to
Howard Stern or something okay and I
it's definitely the candles the candles
makes me think that you're masturbating
in there if I'm not pissing in there I
don't know I come in there I'd be like
comments we've really thin like no key
super yeah coming would be even grosser
didn't do because it doesn't really
dissolve does it no it would just stick
to my chest care I'd stand up what do
you do when you when he's in the back
how do you unwind don't really keep well
a lot of the time I really like I got a
fraternal twin brother and he's know are
you guys you're not identical no no
that'd be so I don't know why you there
being okay go ahead wouldn't know yeah
there's somebody like but yeah he he
added sir podcast actually shout out to
Tony he doesn't like to be on camera
though but normally like if I'm relaxing
at the end of the night and I'm free
we're playing video games together and
then like or with Gus and jakey as well
there's all you guys all hang out like
in person yeah we're like wolves are
like real-life close friends like how
nice what a sweet beautiful thing you
guys have they're like like yeah Jake
yeah I like taking late video games with
them like last night and we also talked
on the phone I talked to Jake II pretty
much everyday I think you talk on the
phone yeah for
for usually like well we'll play games
we usually catch up like midday if
something's going on I find that
interesting that you guys chat on the
phone
I like next thing that texting is just
like what he talked about everything boy
stuff
I don't know bath bombs no yeah so I
didn't know that people talked on the
phone I feel like I almost feel like I'm
offended if somebody calls me oh no I
love them I just want text because I
don't I don't the whole act of being
alone to me feels just so intrusive are
you bad at like returning images no see
I am too and I feel bad so especially
like a closer circle of friends on the
rare chance that somebody calls me I try
to let him know on the phone as likely
you did the right thing do this all the
time like call me whenever I prefer that
huh I like people to leave me alone
do I I do like that no one ever calls
anymore nobody does no one well I don't
answer I swear to God even I it doesn't
matter who it it could be like the only
person I answer is Papa John it was a
from a private number and I knew it's
Papa yeah but like I'll answer scam
calls it's not scan likely I'm not you
know what those are the the ones I do
once I can't do is if somebody cold face
times me like video face there is angry
I yeah well I have a hometown friend
that does that all the time and I keep
telling him I will never answer you're
just sitting on your phone then you see
your own face back it's scary it's scary
yeah the phone call to me is just it's
like text first of all here's what I
want to know what do you want because
you're locked in so I say text me tell
me what you want and then I can decide
if it's phone call worthy and it's not
what do you tell them that well I say
you know how that bone has Auto thing
I'll say text me how you scroll up yeah
and it goes to text me oh I get you and
then say hey so now now you've outed
yourself I know if I give you a ring
you're just gonna be like on the couch
just know I won't answer I'd like to
know what why you're calling me
yeah why would you ever call me Gus if I
was in a bind
okay hey what if Eddie's not have in the
survival kit and I really want to show I
like helping people I just want to know
what is going on yeah because so many
calls me to talk about just how are you
doing that's not a conversation I'm
interested in having I'm not I'm dad
won't want it I don't because I'm fine
yeah how are you I'm fine yeah and
frankly I don't want to reciprocate I
mean I think it's fair people know that
you know everyone's got their personal
preference and and I just you I just
feel so guilty I think a lot of the time
because I'm so [ __ ] terrible at
responding to anything so when I do
finally have somebody I am able to
communicate the best when I can talk to
somebody so if it's somebody that I
haven't like texted in a month and we
get them a ring then for me it's a great
opportunity to be like hey I love you I
appreciate you like I want to talk to
you like I'm sorry I'm so bad at getting
back just call me whenever like I mind
that fixes it I have great text
conversations like that really I can't I
can't have you know text conversations
actually because well okay for the ones
we have yeah we do haven't had any okay
I don't believe we've have we had text
conversation we've DM briefly yeah but
they've been fantastic
face-to-face yeah now here we are
conversing this is a conversation yeah I
do like that I prefer it I frankly don't
like face-to-face conversations either
really nothing I want to be secluded and
unbothered I like doing the podcast but
you know it's weird is that I would
never like if you guys came to my house
it would be not like this for sure
mm-hmm
what would it do you think it would be
like more I was like what do we do next
er yeah what do you do it at someone's
house we I mean we like having people
over yeah we start the thing is I think
I don't want to make us sound like we're
super social cuz most nights were not
doing anything but we really like people
like having people over and usually it's
like you get one kind of passive
activity to do like oh we have smash on
the TV that's great then let's all talk
and drink I don't drink I don't smoke
mmm I do love smash that's good
that's a huge thing that's I've always
got to have to smash on the team what's
smashed you guys play now more of
ultimate but we
mainly at our house 64
really I never went beyond 64 that's
fine though dude I just in the last year
I just got good at smash enough to
survive I've been playing since I was
six at birth game [ __ ] and I was just
like alright next year I'll learn next
year here like u-turn in 12 18 20 I'm
like how the [ __ ] have I not gotten this
down yet
I played thousands of games of smash and
just sucked and now I'm a four out of
ten oh it's a brutal game I mean the
arrival of the fittest yeah you know
speaking of coronavirus memes here is a
corona in the shape of a virus pretty
cool
there's a man sipping a corona virus
patient zero can I do some of these are
just awful dumb I mean it doesn't make
sense he's not even aged he's not even
Chinese should be Chinese what makes it
funnier to me is the wikiHow Waterberg
somehow we got to what is that check
mark it's not even good and frankly it
doesn't make any sense
mhmmm who added these who made the same
album I don't know so Ian just whip them
up Reaper somebody put this together I
want to know was it it was me okay Zack
so Zack tell me the blame this means to
me
you know I thought it was something you
wanted quickly okay I mean I like that
it's there's a conversation music now
this one Zack you're gonna help me out
on because I didn't get it at all
so go ahead let's see this one says
killed by alcohol and temperature above
57 degrees okay and it's pointing at
what looks like cells Zack what is the
go wait this is a meme wait so is it
Betty didn't have ice cold Corona and he
died because it was warm is that the
joke Zack I believe so but wait oh man I
don't know how you got that hold that
together wait I still don't get it 57
like a big I guess that's that's like a
Corrupter referring to a corona beer oh
and I'm like having a fever like they
had a warm beer and it killed them I
think
by alcohol no the virus is killed Oh
we'll see the virus gives you a
temperature but they say they say they
say the look at the headline world of
buzz calm
experts say deadly Wuhan virus can be
killed by alcohol and high temperature
just seems like I'm actually not getting
this one Zack wait scroll down yeah
isn't it part isn't the thing bullet
yeah it's like just oh this is one this
is one unit I don't know I just see my
aunts Facebook feed I said the Quran so
if I can critique this meme a little bit
I want to consider 57 degrees high
temperature but in that like snow but
you want up inside you want a drink of
your own okay that's fine I mean we're
working on me and the squad trying to
catch the corona so we can skip work
okay this one I really don't get Zack we
did it boys coronavirus stop I kind of
like that I just thought they were goofy
wait like I don't get it I like this one
it's like that it's this terrible global
epidemic and no one just had the
foresight to feel like why don't we just
ask him to stop yeah and they
immediately give it AI wow I didn't
really I didn't get all that what do you
want texture like swine flu Ebola we did
it boys
stop okay alright do you think this is
overall good or bad for Coronas branding
obviously like in this brother of that
people go corona must I scared but then
how many people are going much name
recognition yeah I was actually at a bar
a couple of days ago and they were out
of Corona which might mean that people
are buying no I've been thinking about
Corona so much yeah I kind of want one
do you think they made this virus I've
been hearing there are conspiracy
theories that it's engineered really I
think that it's a whole new I think at
first I was like wow Corona stocks can
be taking a hit yeah now everyone's a
corona corona virus that
as weak as [ __ ] yeah quite off aronia
virus over and over a virus snapchat
road like hello okay well I thought they
were goofy I like that I agree Zach I
mean I'm oh I see a classy pool when I
love that former owner so we got Winnie
the Pooh and winning the class he is
coronavirus Winnie the flu I like that
mean for hey give it up everybody
this one gots me you know what goes
great with coronavirus Lyme disease
that's an unfortunate oh this one came
straight from stair cat calms not calm
everybody
damn not like I'll get it one of those
old I Can Has Cheezburger I missed those
sites world happy Chinese New Year's
China that's funny
if the Chinese would stop eating bats
and rats that big that's one you see
from your uncle on yeah that's the uncle
that comes to buy peanut every year
that's like five new Michael Jackson
joke city that this one's from meme fool
calm so again shut up
that is true though it is said to have
been originated from eating feral meat
really yes a bat specifically I should
stop eating feral meat then damn we'll
try to cut that back yeah Oh something
so this kind of yeah you should protect
leer elated to our conversation the
corona virus spreading to the United
States Homer Simpson's nuclear reactor
going down and Homer staring at a
picture me laughing at coronavirus me so
this this is basically if there was a
world ending event just basically I
think something a lot yeah I like that
one
twenty20 World War three kicked it out
oh but the corona virus is actually the
one that's back in the bar I dig down no
one's good
thank you
8020 plague 1920 play 2020 anti-vaxxers
are sweating it out I dig it I mean I
think we're all sweating it out
is that Robert Pattinson he's got the
same strut I don't see 82% okay well how
do we how did we headed Zack do the last
one the last Neiman there's my favorite
oh it was okay oh yeah let's I skipped
over that one cuz I felt like the
segment was dragging on portfolio as a
whole I would give a four out of ten but
the text one is an 8 out of 10
well let's this is X favorite
coronavirus yeah saw them open back in
1986 opening for anthrax this is one
that makes sense that it just makes
sense
there were like no good zinger ones like
those were like the only ones I could
find they're just like remotely goofy
yeah I feel like the requests for Corona
means was was kind of doomed from the
outset I don't know if there's really
you know it's just mind-blowing what's
too easy it's too easy the format is
stacked against it there's not a lot you
can do with it well I I certainly
enjoyed I enjoy doing that now if you
wouldn't expect it there are YouTube
pranksters on flights shouting that they
have the weirds me out especially in his
interviews Mediasite shows James Potok
being escorted off a plane while being
cheered by passengers it's the aftermath
what Potok says was supposed to be a
joke I just returned from a flight from
Hunan Province I might have said this is
the capital for coronavirus and I said I
don't feel too well he's so humorless it
was really just to create a viral video
the west jet pilot didn't find the joke
funny
the crew segregated him as a precaution
and the plane was turned around
[Music]
I would have opened it here instead they
were supposed to Villa to Pearson
International they're supposed to go to
Jamaica and they got routed back to
Toronto oh my god out about somebody
like him and I feel like I'm seeing it
more and more often is like he's not in
denial about like wanting to be famous
off of something dumb and he's not even
like accepting more yeah he's just kind
of like yeah I did this shamelessly
clearly it was a bad thing to do but I
wanted people to see me yeah like [ __ ]
man I don't know what's even thinking
right that's so sad yeah just that
desperation mmm it's numb to it I don't
know I tried it didn't work yeah it's
disappointing if there's an if there's a
bad idea there's a YouTube prankster
that's doing it or has done it yeah that
this follows the rule and Walmart
coronavirus prank this is the lowest
tier possible enjoy this Walmart Sunday
afternoon surveillance cameras catch two
young men possibly in their 20s one
wearing a yellow surgical mask a
handmade sign on his back reading
caution I have the corona boy he sprayed
lie saw helping a beauty items clothing
and produce Joliet police say Walmart
estimates seventy three hundred dollars
worth of produce was lost the cleanup
was more than 2,400 dollars though
Courtney these customers confronted the
men still they got away and were last
seen leaving the parking lot and a white
GMC Yukon authorities say they don't
believe anyone at the Walmart was
exposed to the coronavirus I just you
know what really got me was this image
of him with a taped on sign because I
have grown a virus it's like yeah look
at this that's a hell of a prank that
process behind that do they think it's
funny before they leave the house like
it's so lame as the thing yeah did they
record it because it must have been for
you too
yeah must have been the prank is still
spraying everything with Lysol it
doesn't that's already like an issue
before doing the coronavirus stuff right
I think the problem what is Lysol is an
anti in fact and I think so yeah so
you're not supposed to eat that on Apple
for example fix the promise that you got
these things really dumb people that
want to put videos on YouTube and
they're just so dumb they don't know
it's a bad idea man that's it you know
so here you have it that's to me that's
one of the saddest things we're like
obviously these guys like that was so
[ __ ] dumb and it's pathetic but I
just I feel bad that anyone would it
just makes such a pathetic decision like
that they must I mean I think you can
really unpack that they must have a
they're unloved
yeah I'm have to be unloved to go into a
grocery store and do that right ela I
can't get over the interview with that
guy like he was a guy yes really was
there's multiples what is he's we're not
off by anybody yeah I resent that it
seems like he probably enjoys this in
some way though oh yeah yeah and he has
the to talk about it I love how he goes
I may have like he's trying to be all
legal about it like bro it's the
aftermath what puto says look at it was
supposed to be logic really hard from
the province I might have said this is
the capital a lawyer said I don't feel
too well what made you want to do that
well it was it was really just to create
a viral video it's like why he's
confessing so we're worth come it seems
like a whole reference
he's like confessing to the police or
something yeah it was a separate
interview that I saw before this one I
think it was that night where he's in
his hotel room and very briefly I think
his like dad opens the door and clear
and he says like off camera like they
just came in as in like the media is
just in here that's why I'm talking
about it's like no you let them know you
are gonna be happy as a legend I just so
many people just don't have like the
long-term thought process for some of
this shit's like what do you expect the
long haul is gonna be for you here you
know you're the coronavirus prank kid
there's your week of no door
yeah there was um there was these one
youtubers who did a plane prank that
went all wrong what did they do that's
when they beat the guy up on America you
know they that so that was not them but
there was really a bomb or something
yeah oh he's an Arab dude he was doing a
terrorist prank yeah and then didn't way
to grow he was trying to like pass it
off like he didn't say any crime he was
just kicked off the flight right on
video right what I like is we're all
talking about it and it took us a second
to even remember what he did I don't
know it's not worth it he actually is a
somewhat famous youtuber although I
don't remember his name but he yes I'm
surprised it's great doesn't look that
young you like to do something so stupid
can you imagine being that to his dad
you're just like what have I where have
I gone wrong everywhere the true answers
you're trying to talk to him he's going
no I realize I was just trying to make a
viral video he's giving you the PR
answer get you bad supposedly I have
show love for you so here's another one
I don't know if you guys saw this but I
love this I don't know what this one oh
good so this there had a pious PTA
parent-teacher Association meeting and
he's complaining about his son
facing bullying and racism kind of see a
Mexican man that is a Mexican man okay
well observed here we go when I went to
his bedroom to say goodnight and he was
crying because of the abuse he was in
this school system
actually I got it I love this laughing
yes that nobody's taking answer that
what a way to be the big man I can't
believe I mean he thinks he's so right
glasses guy that yeah here you can see
by the way can we soundbite this like
the minute there's like emptiness and I
do want to hear that again yeah I mean I
mean imagine like what a goon the guy's
talking about his poor son getting
bullied
I love his face look at that because he
realizes that the entire room has just
turned on this dude yeah that's gotta
feel good for him
is that his wife do you think sitting
right right next to him I don't think so
so that's a good question because I was
like who the who what this black of a
soul would even bother going to a
parent-teacher Association meeting you
know what I mean yeah might be her on
the laptop
it's just everybody just dogpile again
which is well-deserved I this one it's
one of my favorite moment yeah what I
just I love people that have such broken
logic and situations and to just think
this is gonna land so that's one of my
favorite videos online that that Call of
Duty eSports clip yeah where I
apparently what the guy said was taken
out of context that you're going home
you ever seen that one no pulled up well
there's also what do i type it sound
like a slur in it so I don't know
whatever YouTube stuff for you have a
blank slur oh I think we could get away
yeah it would be I don't even know like
you're going home you [ __ ] but
apparently that's not the word he said
according to him yeah it's hard you
gotta hear it but it's I love those when
a room turns on some funniest thing in
the world to me this it's the second
ones that one yeah oh I don't know
that's okay that's that's fair use
that's on
[Applause]
that's what he's 71 yeah what his what
his defense was and if you listen you
can kind of hear it too I think he does
actually call him a fan as in you're
like not a competitor but you know that
thing that nobody would ever say you're
going home your friend that's true I had
hurt again I have no dog in this fight
I had heard like you I think you brought
that forward to me that he'd actually
allegedly claimed he said fan well cuz
I've been enjoying this video slightly
longer than 2017 and and and this one
doesn't have the room turning on well
it's right the non curb at it has it he
definitely said I would I would of
course why would he not here okay let me
find the real one cuz wow there's some
very vulgar titles here the only reason
I'm ready to accept his defense too is
cuz I've loved this video for so long
and then when I saw that defense Irie
listen to it I was like wait how was I
have been wrong this whole time look
what I typed look at the top what that
metadata is coming in pretty close take
it off I don't know it's probably that
they don't show results I'll be like a
daily movie you're going home you you're
going naughty where you nobody should
ever say that word never probably has it
it's 11 seconds it might still have I
think the cook
[Applause]
I can hear the end one man you won why
would you do that in the moment of
victory and everybody just like hold on
guys I know nothing about the situation
I'd like to think how would anyone think
that they could just get away with that
in the moment it has heated up is that
like he was charged up
well inky says fan I really know okay
hold on hold on what do you know who
this guy is I know nothing I only know
because I think that would inform a lot
of what he actually said but there's no
like there's no scenario like if I sit
here like doctor dr. strange and I
calculate every possible
there's no universe and where I say
you're going home you [ __ ] fan like
you mean he's not a professional player
and a that someone was telling me within
the last few months that and again this
is me quoting a friend I heard but I had
heard that that is kind of a common
insult ammo is yes yes yes go Orson I
believe you said that I was looking for
an explanation and his explanation is
it's an acronym for fat ass nerd is the
worst defense that me cuz yeah like in
that line of like law like makes sense
in my head if you call someone a fan
like they're just a [ __ ] fan I mean
showing up but I played counter-strike
for years years and I've never once
heard somebody who's that never bad
damn that's our best evidence right now
- let's hear again
[Applause]
I into your end I don't know I don't I
don't care about this guy I'm no clue
right I don't hear the G yeah but I love
everybody really turned let's slow it
down by the way poor taste yeah bad just
bad sport alright yeah even if no matter
what he said I think that he deserved to
get turned on he just looks like a dopey
thank you for just helping I'm sure that
guy tries to escape back clipping all
the time I just brought it back up yeah
Oh check this out what's up what are
your thoughts on this clip this guy was
so excited to see Alpo pay the Pope I
went no no that pizza doesn't look good
and it can't be cut I don't know what's
going a little bit less the Pope that
you should throw like a frisbee ins Pope
really didn't move there that's like
trying to get it right it's almost like
a little dance let me watch bro I'm
surprised the pulp accepts food from
people in the streets that seems like a
health risk yeah you know his social
secur earned his social security his
security detail what are you doing hey
doesn't want to get run over
through the Pope who travels in style
dance yeah what a ballsy move regardless
of what he's holding up like you rushed
the popemobile and you're like he was
trying to cram some in his face did you
see that video the Pope slap in that
lady's hands couple weeks ago yeah I
loved it too so deserved [ __ ] that lady
old man is wrenching he apologized but
you know what you probably was like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah well I'd hurt to he's
had like wrist surgery like apparently
and regardless it's like what is he 87
or something like that
don't wrench on him I love he should
have slapped her in the face yeah I love
it I love that the guy s hand delivered
a pie to the Pope and the Pope he
accepts the pie that's true
hmm if that was like if he ate it and
like that was like the assassination of
the Pope was just this [ __ ] guy coming
in the streets and just handed a piece
of ass that day of reckoning that sign
of hope gets killed by a Papa John's
Pizza it all connects to a JEP oh yeah I
almost like docks my other side of my
family last Acholi soprano Oh
first name Tony your optimist primavera
welcome to Papa so not enough cuz family
I wanna see the Pope to a one bite
review of that pizza you know
bar stool it the Pope died who did it
from that yeah we're good we got it all
Jase station you guys I'm sure followed
that whole thing keeps I see it on
Twitter I I'm not gonna get too far into
it just to say that he did the whole
death hoax he pretended his girlfriend
died but here's here's actually where it
got interesting is that it's Toronto
police confirm that Jason ether that's a
unfortunate last name yeah it's here
yeah probably French would appear he is
due to appear in court so we don't know
for what but
she said she said that that he hit her
really yeah and we all we couldn't tell
if it was a hoax or not because he
burped you know what's crazy what really
happened ela which is so [ __ ] insane
and was what I predicted but I thought
it was too crazy but they broke up and
then he made a video pretending she died
however they broke up because he hit her
she left and then he made a video
pretending she died just for content and
to explain why she was gone but of
course she's alive and then she made a
video saying like no I'm alive and he
beat me again it's the short-term thing
because yeah I thought well that's that
can't be
but he's due in court yeah Zack Zack
Zack stake an issue with go ahead Zack
she was involved in making those videos
she was involved in that that's right
damn but they but so that's high it's
just so weird like wakes her death and
then she made a video saying he beat me
but whatever the case is he is due in
court so all the best to James should a
video of the making of one of the death
hoax videos right and she was in it yes
behind
oh the Ouija board - like live yeah I
mean this is where it like actually
matters but I try not to talk about him
publicly ever just because most of the
time it's such a clear desperate grab
for attention yeah like his like he also
looks like if logic fell on hard times
why don't the bad skinny white guys look
like CSI mind giving guys like this well
it's not good attention a might but it's
also great content so what am I gonna do
I'm saying people always say Ethan don't
talk about them like dude I'm running a
business yeah it's just like that whole
thing is so [ __ ] pathetic to me like
I love it man I live for this this is
what I build my career
doesn't it stress your out thinking
about being that person though where
it's like nope it is involved but that
is just it's so pathetic I could not
imagine how
miserable that would be doing like that
oh he is suffering every day that you
guys see the thumbnail of that video I
was like crying no no no no no so this
is when I knew
wait it's better than that at first I
was like man I'm kind of a fret what can
i I was kind of afraid because I was
like man if it's true that really sucked
but then I was like well there's no way
it's true but when I saw the thumbnail I
hope you didn't delete he took it down
we must have wait I thought he had more
subs in this it's I am J station Oh
girlfriend died thumbnail why would your
second channel be your actual name one
you did that backwards
this was the thumbnail oh god that was a
thumbnail you people can make good
YouTube videos why do these people like
not even Tresvant
oh I guess yeah D is it more insulting
or less insulting if he made that or if
he shipped it off to someone else to
make that oh where we have to give J
station let some credit she's in heaven
it's so heartbreaking was just like you
know what I thought to myself though if
she did die this it would be worse if
she did die and that was the thumbnail
yeah he would still do it if she
actually died I think right oh man I
think you're right the bubble like wow
the really dark dude sorry go ahead no
I'm still I hate you a question really
hit me hard
I don't know yeah I can't tell like you
think he made it or said I think he made
it
you know there's a really good glow yeah
that it can do that you think he
outsource it on like Fiverr you know
it's any you know it's even what he said
she was killed by a drunk driver like
it's not funny
the only horrific thing to say yeah you
know what I mean Jesus Christ she was
she died yesterday she was hit by a
drunk driver and then and then he goes
see you guys should've watched it and
and all she wanted to do was hit 300,000
subscribers on our channel together damn
J station he goes he goes we banked like
five videos so I'm gonna keep uploading
those in her honor so if you guys will
go video msn like but with our
conversation of like me not caring about
growth at all I can't understand these
people I don't get the competition see
you need to get in his mind videos like
Gus died he was murdered by it he was
where he was raped and murdered Wow yeah
they found his body where the I did it
what's the conspiracy that guy had
talked you can talk so she went on to
make her own channel yeah laughter yeah
well I never I never took anything they
did seriously but now that the police
confirm that he is due in court yeah the
thing if they if he was actually
suspected of beating her up they would
just arrest him one day I assume yeah
well because I don't you know you can't
trust the headline for it but did that
headlines they charged with assault was
he actually charged because that's what
I thought that headline said um let's
have a look and it is also on you know
like it says Professor Burton he has
been arrested and charged with assault
and assault with a weapon whoa
see that sounds pretty serious damn it's
not clear if the charges are related to
the hoax
oh it's not clear this is the type of
thing where I think his channel should
just get shut down I'm sure it has well
even before this use that's why
sometimes I don't get you to lie cuz
they have rules then they go a good
stand like stand on so just they don't
yeah and then they would on like really
dumb [ __ ] like there's some home run
like they were having great press for
all that we're deleting Logan Paul's
channel during that whole thing like
they would have gotten great press for
it
but I don't know why you imagine like
that have been a year's worth a clout
for Susan just do whatever she wants to
me if she wouldn't if she deleted his
channel though yeah J station I think is
Paul oh yeah yeah wait yeah yeah
wait but I think they're just they're
trying to they're trying to be like
they're not trying to be the police
they're just the plyo and I think
there's League already approached two
days but this is becoming the most
[ __ ] because there's legal
ramifications for being a platform first
a mediator hmm like there's greater
inherent responsibility but means
differently to the FCF the federal
communicated
okay this was my voice to it picked out
like an important this is my favorite
moment of the year you guys call this I
know I watched some Larry King I don't
want is a Scott this is David he's a
conservative talk show host and I guess
people III frankly don't know I'm just
gonna give the backstory as far as I
know because people are dunking on him
for this
he's very passive I guess people people
make fun of him so they're dunking on
Dave
they're ducking on Dave for this one so
Larry King's on his show and they're a
key detail here is that Dave Rubin has
said that Larry King is his idol I mean
he's great but like Larry King's your
choice there's better options bro I mean
great interviewer but I'm not I don't
have like a Larry King poster in my room
look at his [ __ ] kicks though dawg
Air Force Ones baby no Larry King squall
do you guys watch this alright obviously
beautiful
let's check in I can't I
you don't even Republican moderates I
grew up with a lot of them yeah New York
Herald Tribune
there's some great you Scott a
Pennsylvania
Jake Javits of New York he's a distant
cousin of mine actually oh yeah great a
fascinating conversation yeah Samsung
makes I so I visited that company in
Korea yeah Samsung right and it's
ringing right now it's live by the way
why it's live stream you know knows in
the very I'm gonna pause in the very
beginning I go back and show you but
just take my word for it the Dave's
first question hilarious this is live
does it make you nervous because you're
used to broadcast and you could take
things out yeah he knows this is live
Wow live stream to YouTube with a life
that just wait oh this is [ __ ] kid by
the way oh I think it's as good so
probably forty three then talking to you
the audience is watching me talk to Wow
gotten in your status or maybe you could
do the ten minutes when you open the
refrigerator look at Dave
he wants to do his own podcast 20 years
or breathing he's a great kid
alright Ken when am I gonna see it I'm
dead tonight I'm tied up tomorrow get
into the how about Thursday
I love Friday night all right the night
before you double hit the live switchers
deck is like capturing the wide glove
he's really on it I love you a cannon
you think it's over okay talk to you
tomorrow
what no today that's great the Dodgers
got Mookie Betts and David Price today
you're breaking your breaking news for
me man
hi that's tremendous who did they give
up for them now they're just talking
about dodge your toddler you know do you
think he's no yeah you seem I think
Larry's doing players kid to my age it
was gonna be a star fine indication even
if that's why I like this so Larry
David's not a prankster even any moments
where he's been kind of funny before and
I think especially him saying they're
watching him the thing is if you were
directed at that initial goodbye though
it would have been almost inappropriate
I mean it's a 47 minutes he's on the
phone for like five percent tomorrow by
the Dodgers got wookie bets and David
Price and jock Peterson went to the
Angels three-way trade see you are a
news man breaking news see that that's
my excitement
the thousands and thousands of people
now know them leaky sweaty you really
you love your kids I've seen you employ
I don't know he's no by the way if I
were him and this is why it doesn't
count cuz he probably wants to be taken
seriously that would be the funniest
thing that had ever happened to me in my
entire life I'd be laughing that whole
time he's clearly smiling through the
pain that whole Dave's taking heat for
then yet because he is so passive are
you know what but but but but obviously
Larry [ __ ] him yeah III know I haven't
seen a scrap of anything Dave Rubin
I mean don't know him at all but just
watching this I probably would have done
it the same way where it's it seems like
you said he's self-aware and he's just
like it's funny that I just sit back and
let this play out and know what a couple
subtle things in there were he's just
like you know thousands of people watch
this you know I think he was I think he
was dying inside yeah I think I think he
was panicking I'm disappointed that he
didn't just cuz if this happened to me I
wouldn't go adored it I was like so
[ __ ] funny but I think he I think he
was dying inside and panicking yeah but
he's not a comedian he's not we don't
you know he has a serious show yeah like
if your hero is just pretty much giving
you the finger for like five minutes but
I just I love this and then the second
wind like and then he was so long like
that like his son is like letting him
wrap it up he's like no no what have you
seen because that's a thing do is I know
Larry is still extremely prolific he
does all his stuff on like I hear
something in back like someone having a
heart attack everybody live back there
Dan everyone okay I mean how old is
Larry King he's in his night right
hundred 200 he was a day behind her
teenage no but this the thing is he's
still doin [ __ ] all the time like and he
seems to be with it for the most part
yeah but my one of my favorite recent
Larry clip at kinkle 86
it's from he's only 86
that is old but he looks he looks like
the grim reaper but have you seen the
the snippet when he's talking to Norm
Macdonald and norm does you know norms
joke about I'm a deeply closeted gay man
mmm no no that one at all I don't know
how easy it is can you pull that up at
all do i there was a little king one
that I was trying to find to show you
and I couldn't so you want me to watch
Larry King V noir McDonald's the closet
I don't know if it's gonna be a clip at
all but it's it's his deeply closeted
gay man bit and the thing is norm goes
around and he does this on other shows
it's one minute long and what something
people don't know about you so Larry
never gets what are you revealing I'm
deeply closeted that means you're gay
that means you're very very gay but you
don't want to come out so closeted
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's a great like I've seen norm he
goes Ron does this every doesn't conan
tony gets it instantly such a great joke
that you can play it off everyone listen
your norms amazing I love I tell you
what my favorite noir moment he got in
trouble for well what did he say on the
view oh the Roseanne Barr stuffer What
did he say I don't remember at all he
said something offensive but he made it
worse he went on Howard Stern what do
you do to do an apology he was on a
whole apology tour because he had a
Netflix show and he wanted yeah so then
on the Howard Stern Show and I'm
listening to it live he's talking he's
saying some joke about someone with Down
syndrome well you were saying like cuz
he was saying to think that that's what
I meant when I said whatever he said
yeah you know the story sucks without
the detail I'm just I just pulled up I
just found an article yeah you would
have to have Down syndrome to think that
that's what I said right right he goes
you'd have to have Down syndrome to
think that's what I said and then
there's the buckle awkward pause and he
goes did you hear me I say you have to
be [ __ ] you'd have to be [ __ ] no
on the apology tour what is it that he
was apologizing for the original comment
on Howard Stern Show where he said you'd
have to have down syndrome not to feel
sorry for victims of sexual abuse Wow
good one what was the apology for dan
that's what I want yeah yes it was about
I must know what that's what I just told
you what he said what he said a louis
c.k What did he say that was offensive I
don't remember I thought I was a Rose
Ann thing I have no idea I think he was
siding with Louie CK during that whole
that's it no it wasn't even his own
controversy that was just RKO'd it's
like you get you get so like lost and
controversy it's like I didn't even
[ __ ] do anything I didn't I didn't
even save the original thing and now I'm
on the radio saying [ __ ] what a mess I
think that's what it was something like
that yeah it's norm doesn't seem like a
guy that's good for doing a PR - I love
it now we're pulling up the clip - with
the Larry King stuff there's one
interview where he asks Jerry Seinfeld
if Seinfeld was cancelled oh yeah
Jerry's just such a dick about it and
we're like I kind of side with Larry for
it didn't sound like anything I don't
think it's sure I've seen that one a lot
of time I like it what I think about
current day Jerry then yeah I want to
hear that
I got a sketch I'm brewing up I still
got to make it so Seinfeld's my favorite
show hmm Curb Your Enthusiasm is my
second favorite show
modern so comedians and cars with coffee
is
is very corny mm-hm and what was your
question I mean he's not a hundred like
what's your opinion of me was okay he's
good I felt like comedy wise I've seen
modern stand-up from him and I'm like
you know some of them miss but I still
think that like he's got a really strong
act I just
I think he's so [ __ ] pompous with you
oh yeah sure yeah it's clearly him and
Larry kind of split off in two different
directions with their content for it
like that's what I love about curb is
like even in the new season he's talking
about getting his ticket validated he's
totally right because I got elevation
ashamed I had like I was trying this
therapist or whatever but every time I
would go out there it's like they offer
validation but then when I ask it's like
she gives you this attitude like do you
really need it and then every time she
would not give me enough really yeah
he's absolutely right thank you for
sharing that
he's definitely yeah so brave
he's definitely Papa's he I think he I
even heard him say on what's pompous
arrogant on on Stern he says he thinks
he's on the spectrum people don't want
that like people wanted like he's on the
spectrum
Jerry is he do you think he said that on
how wait
that I understand it to a degree because
you can't just continue doing what Jerry
did when you become Jerry Seinfeld but
then the thing is I've seen him on
comedians and cars being really elitist
about comedy like he I don't think he
can sit I could be wrong but I think he
said that if you're not a stand-up he
doesn't consider you a comedian yeah at
all when I hear him talk about comedy
it's like he's just some he's just
obnoxious when I love him as a person
he's very unapologetic
such a purist approach about everything
yeah we drink coffee how he eats his
cereal and how you do comedy is also
very autistic but I feel like I just
lovely ritualistic yeah yeah very
ritualistic yeah which is a symptom of
being on this well I really I just
looked it up and apparently after he
said that he later clarified to Brian
Williams in an interview that um he was
joking like well well Howard Jones
self-diagnose yeah Howard said do you
think that there's something with you
because he's he's so peculiar are you on
the spectrum at all and he says I might
be because you know he has a certain way
and maybe a little lack of empathy in
certain ways and yeah I won't be
surprised a little Asperger II I think
that lesser Asperger is good for anyone
I mean I'm well I guess they called a
spectrum to certainly have traits that
are very like detailer you on this back
that no I've never been formally
diagnosed with anything except I can't
use Old Spice Fiji because it gives me a
rash but other than that that's the
white now I'm wearing it right now so
I'm on the opposite end don't hug me
no but I think that Larry is able to
find that balance though like Eddie said
yeah they split off and obviously it's
like Larry's essentially I like a
billionaire pretty much but he can still
get away with it because he is often the
butt of the jokes and it still is that
like I'm obviously rich but I can still
nitpick digitation but it doesn't come
from like an elitist perspective as no I
think Larry oh they're so dead I mean I
there's this whole yeah behind the
scenes like a 50-hour behind the scenes
Seinfeld thing that it's like I love I
mean I'm I love this show is there that
much behind the scenes oh it's like this
it's like a documentary with like 20
parts it's so compelling
but there's so different people and
Larry is very much he's very more
emotionally mature there's a story they
tell but as soon as they say Larry was
an awful stand-up and Jerry was pretty
good but at they were at a party and
Larry had written jokes for his
girlfriend for a birthday which was such
a bad idea already like a birthday gift
and then he and then they're like okay
tell the jokes Larry he's like I don't
want to I don't want to and Jerry was
there yeah and so he gave the jokes to
Jerry and Jerry did them really good and
they discovered that Larry's jokes
through Jerry was like the golden ticket
that's what I think is also with her
then that Larry has to be that character
version of himself or to like super
deliver yeah and yeah with something
like stand up your you do that but he's
also been hilarious just in interviews
that I watched with him and everything
Larry yeah oh yeah he's a gem I think
either one I think I don't for Larry
that's the thing is a lot of women love
Larry Dave's got good style
yeah ex care of himself mmm he really
takes care of himself
you can tell ya I just seems kind of
edgy it's kind of like he looked way
worse younger yeah you see I'm like you
ever see clips of him on Fridays that
old sketch show at all no dude look at
some Fridays got his hair was all by the
way last 90 years I have what no
McDonald what it what started everything
yeah what's that
so all it was was that he he said
basically that he was happy that the me
to reckoning with sexual misconduct seem
to have slowed down a little bit because
you know he felt like that what happened
to Roseanne and like Louis DK was too
hard on them because he's friends with
both so he said to himself
why should sure showing your dick to
penis a few time what did I say
showing your penis to gir women a few
times and jerking off in front of them
should that ruin a man's career if he
says it like that what who are we but
mortal it was a dark and stormy night
the louis c.k accusations i find that on
the internet people have swung wildly in
his favor but the accusations are very
bizarre
he's accused of stant of blocking the
exit and then jerking off very mix it's
made some people who know the story
closely say that that's not true that's
just I will say saying that but that's
not the accusations I will say to Louis
CK's defense of all the meteos his
apology and self-reflection was a was
very mature reflective apologetic
and so at what point you know do you let
a man like that returned that's it this
earth
that's a great question it that's what
I'm just so curious about right now is I
think his comeback to some extent at
least more publicly is inevitable and I
just wonder how it he will choose to do
it how he will be accepted and in what
light kind of forms Tony saw one of his
shows that's right I said it wasn't just
wanted not to like like hurt my
brother's image for it it was the like I
want to see what he's doing that full
life what happened to him was [ __ ]
but he said up to him he said yeah I
think I would seem to I'm just so
[ __ ] curious yeah the thing is he
said that it was still good but some of
the jokes seemed almost like rehashes a
little bit he said there was like a
couple of really funny new ones but
there wasn't that thing that I think
we're all expecting is really
introspective he did but from what I
heard from my brother's like he said it
just didn't really like it wasn't what
he was hoping for no it needs to be like
the whole thing is about what happened
here's what hey like two seconds and
then new material yeah here's what I
hope is gonna happen here first of all I
thought that he was gonna disappear for
five years and then come back with us
incredible for five years that yeah yeah
but he but here's what I hope he's got
to stay sharp you as a standard
community you gotta be always performing
but what I hope he's doing is in private
working on these very complicated issues
because if he goes out on stage and he
does this material is gonna get out I
think he I hope that he's perfecting the
perfect redemption Act maybe possibly I
hope that's why I'm just I'm so curious
again like what is the best way for him
to come back you know like a lot of
people are I think it has to be that me
it has to be like yesterday just
football did where like all of a sudden
he came back on Netflix would like those
three new specials and each one way but
he didn't do anything but I know but the
first one was all about like how he was
gone and what happened and like right
yes like stories that related to
Chappelle can just ignore exactly but
the whole
yeah first one was pretty much dedicated
to Iowa's gun so ela you think like do
you think Louie will come back with a
special first or do you think he'll do a
big public interview first I think he
would do a special okay I mean I think I
don't know be special in an interview -
maybe propose a comedian that's a wait
that's not his that's not his strength
yeah he's gotta like express himself to
accommodate if he doesn't give you that
graft he will never come back mmm he has
to do mm-hmm cuz I'm sure pride for
example he smoked crack and lit himself
on fire
he has great he did a whole bit know in
his person you know on stage and he came
back and he had got old funny bit about
letting himself on fire while smoking
crack well Richard Pryor Marlon Brando
news is the craziest thing I've ever
heard in my life news about that they
had a relationship they oh yeah look you
know no not kill Marlon Brando and
Richard Pryor [ __ ] oh well I know corner
of the brand I think was bisexual I'm
pretty sure priors daughter confirmed I
could be wrong Wow I want it so badly to
be right why Eddie broke the news years
ago yeah you knew that I and then I took
a phone call from my son for five what
yeah I know that Brando did [ __ ] dudes
really and by the way talk about iers we
know confirmed yeah I just looked that
same thing yeah yeah Marlon Brando were
lovers priors widow confirms yeah do you
think he kept that cotton in his mouth
what was blowing your mind I just I just
can't imagine these cute guys in bed
together Lee Brando is just like
that dude [ __ ] that guy went through
such an evolution he moves like the most
handsome man to being like Jabba the
Hutt yeah yes you come on me on the day
I can't believe this
what yeah that's the thing is I feel his
bottom dude Randall's bottom hard he's
generating all that thrust he's got
those apocalypse now hips hmm but I or
that virus oh is that bottom bottom
takes it takes it I think I'm gonna say
to you prior one it's called a power
bottom primal power bottom that's what
I'm saying so he was smoking quite late
that's first of all a very short term a
market it for being a power bottom let's
all just agree on a starting point here
bottom is the receiver is it
I believe in bad have too much
confidence that's already are corrected
you can you can invert that there's I
know what I'm saying without the word
power there the bottom is a different
bottom bottom receive I suppose that's
the default that's the default yeah yeah
okay so then I think Brando is top and
then yeah Amil that's what I'm saying he
was wrong about everything
wait were alpha then then but Richard
might be but Richard was like Alf
privado he was all I mean maybe you're
right but like I always said you can't
maybe they like I would say that like I
do you think they have you tried Freud
that is what's that I don't know why I
know it's when you just rub dicks weight
Friday yeah oh I feel like I heard a
different word out of that what is the
word for it you know I had a friend who
once told me if she was gay she would
fry and I was like what is that
wait not with you just in general in
general nobody with me so there you so
there's some Dame to take home I love
that I just I wish cuz it can be a fly
on the wall for a date with them
honestly what do they talk about you
know I heard they had a lot to talk
about it probably brand was just one of
those fascinating guys ever just really
strange interesting dude you ever watch
them unlike old interviews and stuff -
he did like a long one I like the Dick
Cavett show or whatever and it's after
he sent the like First Nations woman to
accept the award on his behalf for
winning the Godfather Best Actor thing
and I think he was like talking about it
and it's just he just seemed so
confident in everything that he was
doing that it was just like this is a
guy that just doesn't give a [ __ ] this
is really interesting like watch an
interview you know so do you think that
like because he like got so big yeah in
that movie on the waterfront he's one of
the most handsome men I've ever seen no
blazing that yeah dude I'm looking at
you his laptop right Brando I wonder
would you [ __ ] II love this for you
Marlon Brando or or what's his [ __ ] Paul
Newman Paul Newman there but you have to
pick or you die it's kind of lipped like
it's a very like pretty boy face you
know Decker you died right lip 100% I'm
still new think I was gonna say Paul
Newman Paul Newman I go newly most
handsome man to ever live and he's so
[ __ ] cool I feel like if I did
anything romantic with with Marlon
either way I'd leave a bloody he just
seems so aggressive just look at that
this was the butch I think this was
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid this
was him at his most handsome that's peak
that's peak Paul right there yep and you
know he was a humble guy he was probably
uh there's probably thoughtful lover
[Laughter]
yeah I mean he was obviously a very
compassionate man he created this
nonprofit yeah that's generated half a
billion I think that's a billion dollars
just for salad dressing I don't know if
it's good salad dressing it is okay it's
really I think we've not crazy about his
products and I like to help charity but
he's dead he won't mind me saying that
his Rolex sold for 16 million dollars
Wow somebody whoever bought that
probably jerked foot there what'd I do
well they say it was Ralph Lauren that
bought it but it was his what a flex his
1960 Rolex Daytona you think you think
he put some Vaseline on it and rubbed it
on his pants because you guys think just
now with the internet and seeing people
so much that we'll ever get somebody
like as cool as that ever again because
part of its the mystery right of only
seeing them and mostly definitely I
think I'm say something stupid exactly
like it just doesn't he doesn't tweet
out like Bill Cosby didn't really do
anything it's probably like DiCaprio and
maybe like Ryan Gosling those guys are
smart because they don't like really
engage so smart he understands how to be
a star he's not a social yeah
the grid I said when he's got a new
album it's everywhere mm-hmm use it like
you should but he's not talking directly
to the people now through social media
that's the mistake I'm envious yeah I
often wonder why am i doing it Bennett
doesn't benefit me at all you know
Howard Stern always says this and I
think it's so true he goes why the [ __ ]
would I be on Twitter making content
I get paid to entertain people here
nobody's paying me to be on Twitter I
would I waste material also now risky
you're making a joke now that's like hey
I'm just trying material and then five
years someone fishes it up from from Vox
or whatever and down and then all the
sudden you're on an apology tour saying
[ __ ]
I mean like really what are we doing
yeah [ __ ] stupid
I just I'm so envious of that I really
do think DiCaprio just from a Hollywood
standpoint right now is like the second
wind of old Hollywood it's like what the
deal between [ __ ] it is pretty similar
to yeah but but like I just can't
imagine being in the public eye so much
like that if I could just swing in and
do a movie every couple years and then
just kind of [ __ ] off to a yacht that
would be pretty chill it seems like well
just try uploading less to a damage
warning me that were at the two-hour 15
why did they do it backwards it's a
woman in a wheelchair of really big
woman she must she must weigh at least
600 pounds being towed what happened to
the audio it's not copyrighted got it
out cause it's but there's a good
there's there's air bring it in for a
sec here he goes only in Kansas folks
[Laughter]
mistake the tumbler on the curb man you
got the new spicy chicken strips only
can you soundbite that you guys yeah oh
yeah all right let me open it again we
can't we can't waste it so would you
consider this truck her own mobility
scooter she's had a breakdown I think so
I think she's being rescued you think
Todd
only in Kansas City you had the demo to
cool you off Kim this right here no wow
she almost takes a tumble really man
yeah like if you fall it that way you
don't get up man again it's just like I
don't envy that life at all that's so
miserable it's the worst Oh
but imagine the amount of cheeseburgers
you can enjoy like I because do you know
I'm not being rude but like last night I
ate a whole pizza to myself and it was
so good yeah and I didn't feel bad about
it at all and like I would like to do
that for every meal I do too
so there's some joy along the way but
then when you realize that uh what what
have I become
my only friends that's probably my
biggest crutch like I like I could just
I can't [ __ ] stop eating I'm so
hungry
especially at night you know I just want
to eat every I just want french fries
and hamburgers and pizza
yeah and Diet Coke I could eat I'm
responsible I drink diet coke yeah there
you go yeah that's smart I could eat
pizza ramen and Thai food for the rest
of my life
ramen I could get really I [ __ ] with
ramen pretty hard you like ramen it's
all right we're like Thai food I'd
rather Asian cuisine stuff I like green
curry green curries good what do you
[ __ ] with a drunken noodle um I came out
with stuff I I get what's going on here
you Chuck are you I can't help you help
when we were talking about the
insecurity stuff I'm always some point
in between I've always been so it's like
I got I don't know you love a flat
stomach not flat no but yeah I feel like
you might look pretty good under there
it's like I still got I still got some
some fatty though it's cuz my yeah my
diet is pretty bad but I still exercise
and when I regiment
um why I just it's an easy one just I
run a mile every day I have since like
my senior year high school and like yeah
I don't know it's just it's only to keep
the lifestyle going of what you're
saying of like eating pretty poorly but
what I loved when I was going to come
College and I was like really getting
into it more I would just have everyday
for lunch I would just have a white rice
with like cut-up chicken breasts and
Frank's redhot buffalo sauce and that
was I could eat it any day but your meal
yeah well that's good mm-hmm dude it
does sound good you have that turbo mode
meal we're just like this is [ __ ]
hardcore like I to fluctuate a lot more
in college too especially like if you
just got out a relationship or something
you're like I'm on the free market right
now yeah I mean if will you ever divorce
me I think I would lose a lot of weight
really but it's not it's not about you
it's it's just that you or you realize
like oh my god I'm unfuckable right now
and I feel bad because I didn't wander
you know I'll know what you're up to
like I'm not I'm just gonna get fatter
try got a kid and [ __ ] now so you can't
for me but um I do feel bad because I do
want you to want to [ __ ] me but I just
look in the mirror and I know that
that's not possible
to fat let's see how that plays in the
courtroom yeah what's your reason for
divorce to fat it's just a temporary
thing though you don't have to sign the
page yeah we'll stick around um let's
see we've got oh so I've got this is my
final thought for you guys before we go
you guys heard about goopes yeah pagina
scented candle we're getting one I
didn't see that maybe five dollars so
here's what I'm thinking we have a
really talented production manager you
are teddy fresh who can like source
anything and I pitched this to him and
he says he can get it done yeah I want
to get a butthole scented candles they
were really I think he can do it well he
says the I wanted to actually smell like
[ __ ] so we'll put like sulfur in it yeah
I then like brown chunks of wax and the
wax and like little strands of fibers
that look like pubic hair Jesus Christ
make where the
like I look like a little but does that
like an anus Oh is there a way you can
engineer it see you blow it out and it
just goes like this still like a little
like one of those like that's a real
fart Wendy Williams fart oh that's her
actual fart plate again isn't that crazy
that's a frothy fart yeah it's a new
foam green would you buy that would you
is it would be expensive that's the
thing would you spend $75 as a gag if I
made like a hundred of them do you think
I could sell them yeah yeah I think so
those are like 50 bucks just it's like
the trying to make money from it
necessarily but you want people to
experience it it's like a bad tasting
bean game thing people will buy it could
just they want to know if it was
accurate you should not you should try
to make it not as gross like what you
beakers yeah make it smell like good
[ __ ] you know good is this supposed
to be like when it's Paltrow's vagina
specific no it's just like it says my
vagina so it and we're gonna get it soon
apparently it's in the mail so we'll
find out say vulva T I like that these
people are in the ad bag the tennis
coach oh it's yeah vote yet says vulva T
let's see what is that what about this
is vulva
it's only a vulva okay really you're
gonna sell that sure for $55 get out of
my life I thought it was like a tea bag
like you're saying yeah I thought it was
tea what the [ __ ] goop you're so
annoying you're actually gonna cut like
you're actually gonna write like try to
make this look fashionable
it's only a vulva okay well it's on your
chest so where's the Volvo like your
vulva doesn't go there you make more
sense on a onesie right on the little
button part they've sold out of extra
large and large so the big girls went
for this one what's the message here to
like it's like they're already on the
defensive like hey it's only a Volvo
like what's the carnot our first date
you're like I
well I think of what it means is whoever
wears that it's gotta prove a sizable
Volvo well the vulva is like the dangly
[ __ ] right yeah it's like the lips
cuz the vagina out the lip interior cuz
there's like sorry this is bad female
anatomy
no the labia is the lips are the labia
so what's the vulva vagina another word
for no it's a specific part of the
vagina I thought let me do it here let
me
Bulba is the external part of the female
genitalia it protects a woman's sexual
organs you're in there let me get a
problem you nobody look at this
obviously so is it like like an order of
operations like the PEMDAS of the
[ __ ] female isn't that like the labia
is the outside lip part and in the vulva
is like closer to weight the little
whole thing yeah the labia is a subpart
you got it you're right we should listen
to the female like yeah wait I didn't
know the vulvas the whole [ __ ] thing
just select another one basically you
know a fleshlight yeah the front part
that whole thing is the vulva
no I don't understand what the shirts
for because there's a lot of like like
the vagina is kind of like a scary
unknown territory that people don't want
to talk about or look at or anything
there's a there's been a lot of artists
you think the shirt helps I do not it
doesn't help me understand cuz I didn't
even know what I think it's a start that
only like it's between girls you know
what I mean it's not gonna do anything
for you
it did educate me I mean why did any
three of you guys know what the Volvo
was backstage next yeah we were talking
about a pre podcast but we couldn't come
back in the end no I did not an ballpark
yeah I guess guys don't know what the
[ __ ] involve it I mean I knew what it
was but then I questioned myself down
hila said yeah the labia is the lips
I didn't say only well I guess somebody
I got it wrong I think we should all
take a moment that Gus was wrong about
that and Gus very wrong hold on I'm just
more of a cervix guy that's my
wheelhouse
can we take anything away from the fact
that X L and L are the only sold-out
sizes I I wouldn't put it past goop to
just not be selling those eeeh and just
about that fat shaming those [ __ ]
they only want Gweneth body look-alikes
I didn't know that they had a food
section that [ __ ]
I hate lifestyle that is weird looks
like she is like a snake oil just
dealers oh yeah and she's still one of
the biggest names in Hollywood I really
like her in movies and stuff it's weird
to make the separation coupe is a night
the [ __ ] at the Netflix though was we
did one on energy healing bro you guys
got to watch at Episode five so you seem
like you really are in the goop right
but but just to kind of workshop this
butthole scented candle so you think
chunks of brown wax are no go I would
say just make the whole thing brown
problem right yeah okay smart wise yeah
I like that each and then what about
pubic
fibers man I would skip you I would skip
the view if you branded it and said that
the wick is like tightly-wound pubes
itself horseshoe but I think a wick is a
wish a wick is a wick yeah maybe a you
know what you're right oh you're burning
it's a brown wax what was it like we
were shopping for a mattress and they're
like the materials were so ridiculous
like no I I saw a hundred thousand
dollar mattress are you [ __ ] kidding
and I was like what why he goes it's got
horse hairs cashmere so but it wasn't
just horsehair he had like a nicer way
of saying it oh I'm unicorn hair but it
was like hey cuz I was like I'm sorry I
laid on it too by the way
oh I think it was horse tail maybe no no
it wasn't that good it was not it was
just a mattress but but you covered the
mattress is just a purple mattress that
they taped horse it's the same thing
with like luxury cars I wouldn't be able
to lay
that that like you can't like I don't
usually eat on my bed but like
occasionally you know I'll have like a
drink with me or something where you
spill a Bud Light on a hundred thousand
dollar mattress well you have you um you
have a you you you have a water
protective sheet so you guys you have
layer protective sheet yeah you see this
is what you're supposed young men not
the shitty cells so you'll get so what
you get is a protective sheet that's
waterproof that way you don't sweat
through and damage and your your
mattress so that goes on the bottom and
then the sheet goes over that you don't
really remove the protective sheet
gotcha definitely recommend that if not
even to protect from spills but the
sweat if you look at your mattress
mm-hmm it gets real nasty
we got really cheap Amazon mattresses Oh
for real yeah I've actually been pretty
happy with mine but now you know it
wasn't like one of the investment
mattresses so now like it had like a
soft and firm side and the soft sides
like not supporting me at all anymore no
I should get a nicer one well as long as
you don't back pain I'd say that doesn't
matter that's that's true mattress yeah
but we just got a new mattress um we
went firm if you wanted I did not I
didn't spend 50 grand it was a four
thousand six hundred dollars okay
which to me is insane is it it's a
laugher I never thought we would spend
that much but I think that's what it
costs for like a high end like normal
mattress
anything over am I wrong I are well [ __ ]
I'm gonna spin on it I bought my 50 or
something I think generally if you're
getting like a not high-end but nicer
one I think they're around like 1,500
because they're seen as like estimates
yeah so you're getting like a nice
mattress yeah and a stick that's not
like too crazy like even before we were
filthy rich not kidding even even before
when we were just like normal people
[Laughter]
even before
you would get I would spend like when we
were on a budget a thousand dollars cuz
but Dan how how much you spent on your
mattress you pleb I pay you enough to
buy yourself a nice mattress not four
grand that's for sure how much you spend
on your mattress
I don't know 600 700 bucks ok I I had a
$800 mattress that from Casper actually
who is not a sponsor of mine and I don't
like working with them the mattress is
comfortable but if they want to come
back and sponsor us I would accept their
grace really bad and I apologize for my
previous because I do endorse the
product playing both sides well listen
I'm just being honest I didn't spend a
hundred grand you know it could have
been worse that's about all I've got so
quickly been going for a long
[ __ ] time two and a half hours
it's a long show that means we were
having a lot of fun sometimes you don't
have as much fun and the time goes so
much slower and you're just you
wondering one can wrap it up this wasn't
one of those times this was a it flowed
flood it glowed and showed no this is
rad though thanks for having fun yeah
Gus a pleasure
Eddy was great to meet you I'm a fan of
your content produce it at the pace that
that fulfills your soul and it really
means a lot oh thank you so much and
thank you for saying that I'm your sole
inspiration role model you say about me
I said soul inspiration and creative
inspiration I've know that's really
clicking with what I think I say the
reason you get up in the morning yes you
want to save me here free I think he
said pretty good there that was
something I think I said no you said bro
show me to help you
you know what you just say I run it back
no seriously yes Rachel fortune and so
what is today Friday sure is Monday is
the Dave ray they recognize going that
way I'm not sleeping at night maybe papa
nervous
it's a nerves I'm nervous we have pot
actually next week we have got Papa on
Monday unusual days and PewDiePie on
Wednesday real all again REO that's
calling it episodes will be posted the
day so that'll be fun yeah
obviously it's all downhill from here
what a great time what a good people and
as you know I have a hard time wrapping
this up so is there anything you guys
would like to say well we in our podcast
by going out of her way to abruptly not
plan it out yeah we'll leave music so
maybe we should just hard cut alright
Paul Newman